Hmm. Hmm. Hmm. Hmm. Hmm. Hello
Amy. Hello. The Leopard theme.
You have leopard jackets
today. You have a leopard top.
Is this just a coincidental or
is there something to this? Well,
I'm a little bit white trash and I want
every, no, I don't know. I I liked,
I liked married with children.
Pulled us up. You don't have to.
I'm a little bit, uh, and I'm trying to
get comfortable. Are you comfortable?
I don't know. You seem comfortable.
[inaudible] fine. I'm with the
king anyway. Okay, so leopard,
Leopard. I like Mary the children. I
don't know. I always peg Bundy. Well,
I was gonna go for Kelly, but thank
you. I like dumb and slutty and a no.
I do have my friend who started pegging
her boyfriend and my phone has peg
Bundy. Whoa. What's her name? She
started pegging her boyfriend.
She got a new boyfriend. His,
I think he's gay. Honestly,
I don't sure. Listen, if you get pegged,
I'm not saying you're gay for sure.
But this guy, this guy,
this guy I think is gay.
And what does she think? They broke up.
She thinks he's getting out when Jesus
Christ broke up. Why did they break up?
He was emotionally unavailable
because he's gay. Wow.
I think he's looking for
something with a deck.
So what was there other signs
with him that he might be,
I dunno. I think that he just was not he,
maybe he's just an
emotionally unavailable guy,
but he seemed to have a lot of
issues around wanting to get Dixonus.
So it seems like maybe he needs to
try maybe a less plastic one. Yeah,
we probably use already trying it.
Don't you think? Maybe. I mean,
I don't think he just,
why would you waste your time with a
rubber Dick Strap to a woman if you could
just go get maybe Jesus. Jesus
made some Christian stuff like,
oh yeah, I don't, yeah,
maybe it's like internalized
homophobia or probably,
or maybe he's just like transitionary
like maybe two years now.
He will look back and go, God, I used
to make girls fuck me in the ass.
I'm was such a dickhead. Why did I do
that? I should have just come out. Yeah.
Or maybe he likes the feminine aspects
of a woman and the rock hard cock part of
a dude. There's a lot of people
that liked that. He needs it to get,
there needs to be like a,
well, I guess that's what a,
he needs a Hermaphrodite as well.
Whitney Cummings was telling me
that those sex robots, you know,
you saw her specialist
administrates robot. There's,
they're really popular where they
have a woman's body in a dick.
Those ones are really popular. All right.
Hmm. All right. You get to live here,
you get to live here. You just,
you just want everything
inside, outside. Give it to me.
I had a guy call into my podcast about
his wife won't peg him enough and he's a
cock, but she won't. Yeah.
But she like, she liked me.
She like makes love to him while she pegs
him and he wants to be just destroyed.
You know, Jesus Christ. He, he's a
cock. He or she won't fuck black guys,
so he's just, he's like, I'm like,
I feel like for what you want,
you should be very grateful. You
have as a woman, that's pretty down,
but there's always more.
So I'm wondering if he just wants more
or if this is the ultimate same with,
but just that's how it is with people.
If you go back to the early days of porn,
it was basically just pizza delivery
man and sorority girls and sex and
everybody had a bush. But
then you look at today,
everyone's gagging and
slapping and choking and spit
and not choking on pubes in
his body. There was none of that
back then. Now it's like standard,
you know? It's like everything
keeps getting pushed.
Boundaries keep getting pushed.
Everyone's getting the fish. Poor Aziz.
It's fuck cause he's watched the
war, the wrong porn disease. Oh,
you got in trouble? Yeah. What a disaster.
Have you seen a special,
I haven't watched it yet.
I watched a clip and it shot so bad.
It's like you see him and then you see
people behind him in the backstage area
milling around and he's
on a seat. It's so dumb.
It's like there's,
there's doors open in the back and
then people walking behind the doors.
It's like some odd artistic
choice to try to be like,
it doesn't matter that I'm up
here. Yeah. Like it's no big deal.
Life still goes on even
though I'm up here,
which means you were thinking that life
doesn't go on and you wanted to show
people that life goes on
too. That's deep. You are,
you are insecure about how narcissistic
you are and then you tried to fight it.
Well,
I was thinking it was the director's
choice or was the director who was the
director? Was it Spike Jones? Yeah. I
think he tried to do something crafty,
which you know, is kind of interesting
in any other format. I mean,
it'd be interesting if it was a
conversation, it was just a, you know,
two people talking and they're in a
public square and you see people milling
around behind them. That's not
distracting. But with stand up,
the more things you have to think about
other than what the person's saying,
the more it's gonna take away
from what the person saying. Yeah.
It does feel weird to
just, I mean, you know,
I go onto the leopard
print jacket sometimes,
but I like to dig myself a little hole,
but the leper print jack is just cool.
It's just funny. It's not distracting.
It's just here she is. I like a,
you know, I have my toy store.
I don't know if you've been
around for any of those sets, but
it's late at night.
You got to wake him up.
You gotta wake him up near Shore.
Just a plastic sword from the toy store.
I spent a lot of time with props. I,
I have fake blood on me most times.
I don't know when there's going to,
I'm going to be inspired to take a
funny picture to make a Prat Fall, fall.
Did you see the pratfalls that
we did? Me and Steven Randolph,
one of the door guys at the
comedy store one was this,
they posted on the comedy store thing.
We did. We challenged each other to,
to three pratfalls. It's so embarrassing.
Listen, after Brody died, I was like,
I'm going all out. I'm experimenting. I'm
having as much fun as I can. You know,
obviously it's about jokes, but
sometimes you gotta really just,
you got to just have your time up there.
The Brody one was hard on everybody.
I was the one making any sense.
That was one that it just like felt
like swallowing a dry rock. Yeah.
A cow. Like how has that car gone?
It just feel he was just such a
big presence. And then it's sad to,
I don't want to talk too much about
Ios gone here cause I know that's what
everyone does. But um,
I did in one and when I did trip
on Iowasca it was right after that.
And it helped me a lot with that cause I
kept thinking about how sad it was that
he couldn't feel us, like hugging us.
Him, we loved him. Brody was loved.
Like we loved that man. He
was our brother, you know?
And that was the sad part.
Well,
I mean I just feel like there's no way
any of us could ever understand what's in
anybody else's brain. You know?
I don't know what's in yours.
You don't know what's
in mind. It's like we,
we assume that there's a similar thing
happening inside our head is other
people's heads. And I think
that's wildly incorrect.
And I think some people are just in pain
all the time and there's not much you
can do as a friend to, to
help them, you know? I mean,
I felt the same way about
Bordain when Bordain died. Uh,
it was just a how to, I don't get it.
I just don't understand how
someone who's so loved, you know,
he has this amazing job, his
a beautiful daughter. I mean,
he has this life that's extraordinary
and very interesting and deep and he gets
to meet these fascinating
people and travel,
travel the world and expose people to
all of these incredible artists and
culinary artists. And yet
still didn't, couldn't take it,
didn't want to be here
for whatever reason.
And I just think about it, it's like,
so they're, they're okay. You know,
they're off wherever we go or
whatever happens. They've transcended,
came back, they're floating
around somewhere. But it's like,
selfishly, I'm like, I want more Brody
like, course I want him back course.
And it's, you know, and then you see
people, they just fade. You know,
like each year goes by and they just,
which is going to happen to all of us. So,
but you know, luckily he
had a lot of catch phrases,
a lot of stuff online or in the
back of the store. Oh, I love,
I kiss it every time I walk by it. I'm
not touching it anymore. Yeah, I lick it.
I give it my herpes. I don't have
herpes yet. Joe Rogan audience.
It's okay. And honestly
if you have it, it's fine.
What am I going to have a vaccination
must have on already they've got to almost
shirt. What do you think?
Conspiracy theorists? Yes. Yes.
Cause he already sparked up when we
talked about the aliens thing with,
did he bring up Ohio? No, I left
it all out. But he got his eyes.
There's just something, there's a spark.
They have conspiracy that they
have a little spark in their eye.
When he perked up, he keeled his asshole
a little bit. When I brought it up,
it was really funny. Like those. The
last question I asked him was about UFO,
just kind of almost as a joke,
but just as a goodbye, you know,
like keep it silly.
That's all I'm reading.
It's in fucking hundreds of articles.
It's all Bernie Sanders says he will
tell the world about aliens if he becomes
president. That's the thing that they
took out of that. Well, it's smart of him.
It feels like Trump's straws. It's
like smart. If Bernie had said,
if Bernie had brought it up, I would've
been like, that is a brilliant tactic.
But don't you think that
people that believe in aliens
are already going to vote
for or that are the most
hung up on it? No. No.
You don't think they're the
same? No, no, no. I think they,
they very wildly conspiracy theorists or
left wing right wing and the alien one
is different than any other one. And I
think there's a lot more people that are,
um, that are alien lovers
that cross both sides.
I think it's just one of
those things where you,
there's guys that fuck
alien done. That's the only,
that's the only anchors you're
holding out to pastor Manhattan. Yeah.
Do People claim that? I bet you
they do. For sure. Do you know this?
People really in the big foot sexually,
there's like all these novels written
about a big foot tall Armenian. No, no,
no, no. Just that hard
to ever go to Glendale.
Everywhere I go to the
Galleria, there's this big foot.
This is a very localized
reference. There's big foot,
you it, big foot or eyes.
You get big foot erotica. Yeah,
I mean it's like really common.
What if he had a small deck?
Like you always hear about the really
tall guys with the tiny decks and when I
say care about them, you hear about
them. Get this seduced by big foot. Ooh,
look at, come for bigfoot Virginia Wade.
Big Flood by Lolita young.
Wait a minute. Narrated.
I mean this is an audio book.
[inaudible] you know what they say?
The bigger the big foot, the bigger
the air in the bones. What does that,
I like a guy with very deck, you
know, like you like to listen.
People say they don't like
too much heroin balls.
I say get her all the way under the
shaft. Look at this boffing big foot.
What is happening? I thought, I feel
like I liked it. Her name's Ann L.
Gay bigfoot. Look at this last
row and I'll probe is gay bigfoot.
Keep smoking after we fucked. What
the fuck? Mouthful of Sasquatch.
I [inaudible]. I've met that man.
There was like one of the
door guys at the comedy store.
That's one of the tour guys. I got fired.
This is a whole genre of erotica.
There's a bunch of women
that write these books.
This Virginia Wade lady is a,
she's apparently very prolific
with her big foot erotica.
She writes quite a few of
these. How many does she have?
That was 13 at least 13 come
from big foot. Come for bigfoot.
Number 13 she just makes shit up.
Then there I was walking the dog and the
dog had a heart attack. The next thing,
big foot stick is in my mouth.
How about I have a good pun,
Harry and the Hummer sons. Henderson Hen.
Don't say Harry on the thinking out
loud and then just sounding it out.
I can't read ever. Leave me alone.
What'd you expect me to come on?
And Boone's fucking smart.
So there's at least 13 books.
I Bet Virginia Wade lives in a fucking
giant match and drives around in a rolls
like the l Ron Hubbard. Probably a dude.
No, it's a, but I get to, I bet it's a,
would that big foot five baby come
for big foot baby. What does that say?
That one home for big foot five
baby. What does it say baby?
See that Seymour right
hand side all the way.
The right all the way to the right
all the way to the right up above it.
There you go. Bam. What does that fuck
is that? Maybe they have a big foot baby.
It looks like a come inside or one.
So she's got, let's find out. Google,
Google, Virginia. Wade's big. Is that
her right there? She looks normal.
It might've been. Was that a photo of
her and go with the goddess? Go back.
It was a different book. They're talking
about. Okay. The ball for big foot.
Does that hurt?
Is that Virginia Wade doesn't normal
looking lady and it might not be her. Oh,
Amazon Poles buffed by big foot
romance novels from shelves. What?
Why are they censoring bigfoot porn
yet? That might've been her. Okay.
Why don't,
why didn't anyone tell me about
these literary treasures? Oh my God.
I thought for a second. The long but
interesting read was about the book.
This is a long but interesting
read. Why are they pulling it?
Why are they pulling this stay
at home mother from Colorado?
Of course she is no real riding
experience. No, of course not.
You don't even have to be good. I mean
she spent all day waxing her nipples.
She couldn't get to come to terms with
their hairy body and then she realized
all she needed was to
find her match. She says,
I get this crazy idea for a story.
So she sat down and wrote
the entire book in an hour.
Bella does no fucking,
there's no second draft.
That's what I love to hear
by my, from my authors.
You wrote this all in one draft.
She said just 12,000 words
in a matter of weeks.
She's been considered trying to sell
it to mainstream publisher instead.
She went directly to Amazon's
kindle direct publishing,
an online platform for self publishing.
70% royalty rate for authors.
I think she sold a fuck
load. I had to go viral.
Here's the line from it if you want,
right? I don't think he's monogamous,
but let's bigfoot na. So big click on
that big foot insider, monster porn,
Amazon crackdown link. So let's find
out what the fuck is going on here.
Why would they crack down on that?
Ooh, ad blocker. You son of a bitch.
It was the tens dude. So hot author,
Virginia Wade's fiction debut falls,
a group of women who embark on a week
long camping trip to mount hood national
forest. They are in the shadow of
Oregon's highest mountains. They're,
they're kidnapped and sexually
assaulted. Posteriors woodland creature.
What the hell is that thing? Ass One
protagonist. That's some good writing.
It's fucking big foot. His Shelley,
he's real. For fuck's sake,
har filled her eyes with
a huge sea dash dash dash.
I'm saying that says
cock corn in the book.
His feet are fucked up with decidedly
un-PC title, like come for big foot culm.
Of course, it's just the first
of 16 fiction ebooks. Wade,
a pen name has written about the
legendary, but sometimes best,
sometimes known as Sasquatch,
each legendary beast.
Each detailing a series of graphic and
often violent sexual encounters between
the apelike creature in a
female lovers. Okay, wait, wait.
Has made an exceptional living
writing these stories. Wow. Okay,
but why did they take them down?
That's reminds me of my
friend from middle school.
His boyfriend who is Sicilian. He
was just so hairy and he looked,
it's been downloaded more than a
hundred thousand times. Holy Shit.
That's five bucks. That means she
made $500,000 for the flipper. Why?
Well, she made 70% of it.
At least I bet you the other
books didn't take as long either.
Wow. During her best months, she's
netting 30,000 or more in a month.
Writing big foot jerk off books. Wow.
Taken by pirates. Oh, she re she
branched off into other genres.
It's all just getting fucked, taken
by pirates, seduced by the dark Lord.
It's like getting fucked by
demons and pirates and hilarious.
I'm getting traumatized. A traumatic
thing is coming up for me right now.
That's weird. Do you want to hear it?
But my mom wrote romance novels
when I was shut the fuck.
Yeah. They were never published.
No, I didn't read them.
They were never published, so it
was really just a fuck journal.
You read your mom's fucked
journal. I didn't read it,
but she had romance novels around and I
would definitely knew I was really good
at skimming to the sex scenes.
I knew how to flip through,
flip my being to, so your mom wrote,
she was a part of this thing
called romance writers of America,
and she actually won awards and
then she never followed through.
So she could have published the
book and probably had success.
And then she had a hole. It was
like a whole suspense romance.
Salinas revenge was what it was called.
She was Lena like the saying no,
but that's really funny. She came
back and she said to fuck bigfoot. No,
she fucks. The girl killed her. Mixed
read it. She's dead. I like that lady,
that little Weirdo. I mean I don't like
her because she killed her, but she was,
she's like a real weird, I mean the
girl killed, see, obsessed. Like she,
you know, she reminds me of, she reminds
me of, and I definitely don't like her,
but she, um, she reminds me
of the little woman from um,
okay. Can't remember
what's it called? The uh,
David Lynch that show
which one? Twin peaks.
Which ones when they're
a little lady in it.
I don't remember twin peaks very well,
but there was a little lady in
[inaudible] imagine the day,
but I just remember usually from the
TV movie with Jennifer Lopez in it.
She plays Celine. She played
Selena. That was her big break.
She was a fly girl and then she got super
hot and that big ass was exposed to us
and Selena outfits. That's
interesting. Why they go killer.
She was their assistant, right?
Yeah, she was just such a big fan.
I think she was just obsessed with her.
So she killed her cause she was a big
fan. People are just fucking crazy.
That doesn't make sense.
It's probably hated her because she
made her wash her laundry and shit.
She was our assistant or I think she
was the head of her fan club assistance.
Get Weird with people. Did you
ever hear the David Spade story?
His assistant tasered them and fucking
tied him one of going to jail? Yeah.
I guess. Was it a girl or a guy? Was he
trying to fuck him? I don't think so.
I think he just hated him. Oh my God.
I feel like spade would be a nice
employer, but maybe not. Maybe not.
Maybe is now it's good taste.
Wow, I didn't know that.
Yeah, yeah, yeah. See if he can find
that store spades at some shit at me.
Got Catfish. He's here. He
gets fished. He got catfish by,
he told it on the norm. McDonald Cho
who catfished him. Someone catfish him.
He thought he had met this
model and Twitter. Oh.
And then he saw them out on real life and
was like, hey Twitter. And she's like,
what are you telling them?
And they say something.
Oh that's so embarrassing. Who did spades?
Coolest shit. There goes David spades
assistant pleads guilty to assault.
Make that larger police. Oh
my God. David pay spades.
Former assistant pleaded guilty.
Stop to assaulting the comedian with a
stun gun and agreed to seek counseling
for drug and psychological problems.
Beverly Hill Superior Court Judge
Elden Fox also sentenced David Warren.
Skippy Malloy on Thursday to
five years probation. That's it.
Two nights straight,
at least named skippy ordered him to
stay at least a hundred yards away from
spade and performed 480 hours of
community service. If somebody tased me,
I want more than community service cause
that's a threat and they tied you up
and shit. How did it say? Wait a minute.
It says David Spade 36 oozes in the 20s
shut the fuck at the beginning of our
call it, oh my God,
he tied him up. How did, I wonder how the
story ended. How did he get out of it?
She just really good
with the untying. Not,
did the guy get tired of
fucking them and get shocked.
G says he was angry in a
psychotic state due to cocaine.
The morning of the attack. I'm Tom
Town. I mean, I've done coke before.
I don't think I've been like, let
me tie up my boss and Taser him.
Never done coke with David spade. You're
right around him. Maybe he's, you know,
telling you to take the dog out and you're
like, I can't do this. I can't hyper.
So the Co said the Costar, the
NBC said, come just shoot me.
The new movie Joe Dirt said at the time
that Malloy a 30 year old aspiring actor
was a friend who is obviously
mentally troubled right now. Wow.
And I'm more shocked by Joe
Dirt as a new movie. Yeah,
we're digging back in 2001
we are digging back. Wow.
Fuck. That seems like a
long time ago. But you know,
it doesn't seem like a long time
ago. 2009 you say 2009 like,
oh that just happen.
Nope. 10 years. A decade.
Like 1960 to 1970 it seems like
forever. 70 to 80 seemed like forever.
80 to 90 seems like forever,
but 2009 to 2019 for whatever
fucking reason seems real close.
Yeah. And it's not, it's
not, it's hot. Whole years
style. We'll show you that too.
Cause I was, I was born in 83.
I'm 36 and uh, the kid, the,
the younger kids right now are
dressing like I dressed in high school.
Like it's cycled back
around there in my styles.
Yeah. But that's then like not 2009 to
2019. Is there a difference in style?
Yeah. This is coming from
someone that's Zeros.
Yeah, there is, what is
it? It's okay. From 2009,
um, I would say 2009 was maybe when
they had started having this one.
I have to remember where I was in
life. I just moved to New York.
People were wearing, I dunno, I'd lived
in Santa Fe and I was drinking a lot.
So I definitely,
I quit drinking in 2009 I was still
never been assigned comedy then.
Santa Fe's was supposed to be a weird
place. That's where I met Tate Fletcher.
Hallo? Caveman coffee. I met Tej in a,
in Santa Fe. He used to come in with
a bunch of sober dudes after meeting.
I don't know if I'm supposed
to say this, but whatever.
He's pretty open about it. But I mean
it was the truth. They were so annoying.
I was like a drunk. I was wasted at this
cowboy bar. To wear a cowboy outfit.
You have to, you have to do,
that's your uniform. Really.
Being a wagers is not humiliating
enough. You will also have to dress.
Just have a John Deere hat
on. No, you have to wear it.
You had to wear a cowboy hat and you had
to have a shirt that had yolks on it.
Oh, if you worked there, if you worked
there and not when you went in. Yeah,
that would be crazy. That would be crazy.
But so table come in with a bunch of
people and they just wouldn't order
outcome. I mean it was just like low
sales, high maintenance. I was like,
who is this fucking guy? So big and
ridiculous. And then I was talking to him.
I hadn't quit drinking. I didn't quit
drinking til I moved out of Santa Fe.
But I told him I want to do comedy and
he made them turn the Karaoke night into
a comedy show for me. Yeah. And I got
[inaudible] first time you ever went.
Oh yeah. Wow. Did you have put
things prepared? Yeah, I just, yeah.
And then yeah. And then,
and then I moved to New York to do
comedy and I was, I crashed my mode.
I had a little scooter,
a Yamaha Zuma and I crashed it cause
I would drive drunk all the time.
I was my happy place. Like to this day
I really was honestly that feeling,
I'm like driving wasted on a scooter
was the wind blowing the air.
Cause you're not wearing a
helmet. You think about them,
you don't really think you can kill
anybody else. So it's not that bad.
A drive drunk.
Yeah. But you can, you can get in the
way of someone else or do anything.
I fucked myself up so bad. I woke
up, just had blacked out completely.
My face was split open. I had
road rash all over my tests.
This was father's Day, 2008 you
don't remember falling? I don't,
didn't all I remembered. I just
remembered like little pieces.
I remembered that someone
helped me. I woke up,
I was living at my friend's
house. I woke up at the house.
He was staying at his girlfriend's
house. So I was there alone,
but my chin was split open. I've been
wearing a dress and it looked like I,
my throat had been slit. Like there
was just blood all the way down it,
road rash all over my tits, all
over this side of my arms, my knees.
Like I just was fucked up,
just face, split open. I just,
I went, I peeled out and like just
went chin first and everything.
And then I remembered
that someone who didn't,
a girl that didn't like me had helped
me. That's all I could remember.
It was someone who usually hated me,
helped me. Wow. And then, so I went out,
I went to the hospital, I called
my roommate, he came back, um,
I went to the hospital. They gave,
I got nine stitches and I was still
wasted and I was still so hammered and the
doctor kept going, were you drinking?
And I kept going just between us.
And he's like, yeah. And I went, nope.
They're like, I'm not gonna fucking jail.
You motherfucker. I was like, no, I
just crashed my scooter. It's crazy.
He didn't know that I didn't wake up
to drink through the pain. So, um,
so then I got the stitches
and I was friends with all
the cops in Santa Fe cause
I was an alcoholic. So
that's a really good plan.
You gotta befriend them so
they don't arrest you. And uh,
they had told me if they had caught me
cause I ended up finding my scooter on
the side of the road. My
friend drove me around.
So I found out where I had peeled out
and there was like a bunch of loose
gravel.
So I just peeled out on the gravel
and the cops said that they would have
arrested me for an Agora aggravated
DUI because I hurt myself.
I'd injured myself. That's
what an aggravated DUI,
that's what they said back then. I mean
I was still wasted when they said that.
That's worse if you hurt yourself. Yeah.
Cause I had to go to
the hospital and stuff.
You would think you got a little
punishment in there. Yeah.
So then I didn't learn the lesson.
I went out drinking that night with
the stitches in my face and I had,
my line was I would carry neosporin
around and ask guys if they wanted to rub
neosporin on my titties. Like almost
lost a nipple. I mean it got so close.
Yeah. I looked crazy, but I was
drunk. So I was like, whew, fun girl.
Yet they still call me fun girl, Andy
behind my back. And I thought they were,
I thought it was like a cool, I didn't
realize they're making fun of all cheese.
So anyway, uh,
so then I went out that night and I
saw this guy with a puppy and I started
playing with the puppy and I was like,
oh your puppy, so cute. And he goes,
do not remember me. And I'm like,
I've never met you before. He goes,
last night I helped you, you crashed
your scooter. And I was like, Oh fuck.
And he's like, I ride a motorcycle.
So I didn't want to call the cops or
anything cause I know you would've gotten
in trouble. And there was like, who
helped me? And he's like some girl.
So then my friend called me,
he's like, my boss told me.
So it was my friend's boss from this
hotel that used to get wasted at,
he was the bartender.
So she hated me because I would
just go get hammered at their nice
establishment.
Do you look back on those days with
any fondness because you're sober? No,
you're all, I'm clean. Yeah,
I mean I think I have a wealth of stories.
I was a juvenile delinquent and I had
so many childhood traumas and abuses and
weird things that happen.
I was running for my life in Jersey City
when I was 15 from like a fake modeling
agent who was like a six foot eight
drag queen named Mahogany running for my
life, trying to hide so long. I just
have a lot of stories and not a story.
You can brush what happened.
You were 15 so I was,
I had gone to Mahogany yet, so I had gone
to John Robert Powers Modeling School,
one of those like fake modeling schools
and it's you pay like 200 bucks and they
make look a compilation
headshot. Yeah. You like go,
they give you classes and
modeling. Like that's a thing.
It's like you either like are
weirdly weird looking alien,
hot and tall and skinny or
not. Yeah. Or you're not.
I mean I maybe could have done commercials
or something. I was cute, but I,
I also had very low self esteem.
It was just such a weird,
it was such a weird thing
to be doing. So, um,
and I had been a Tom boy up
until that point. So we go,
I go to this modeling thing and then we
went to paid more money to go to like a
modeling convention and then they had
actual modeling agencies and then they had
just random people that I get paid to
be there. So mahogany was one of them.
And my mom's like super liberal and so
she likes anything that's like a little
on the fringe that she could brag
about it or book club or whatever.
If that sounds like I'm angry,
I'm not angry. Forgiven. But um,
so they ended up, they were like,
we want to take your daughter for two
weeks and we'll send her out on auditions
and stuff over spring break. And we
have this nice place in Jersey. Teen.
Yeah.
Your mom let Mahogany take you
for so many more stories. Joe.
Jesus fucking Christ. Yeah, no, there was,
my mother did not have anything bad
happened to her when she was growing up.
She was adopted by a very nice family and
she went to a nice boarding school and
stuff and nothing happened to
her. And she read the newspaper.
She didn't read the newspaper. I don't
think much. So she, it just, she didn't,
she wasn't aware. So
anyway, so then, okay,
so I was,
I went to this place in Jersey City and
Jersey City. I don't know how it is now,
but it was fucking crazy back then.
It's still fucked. It was fucking crazy.
So we were in this one little condo and
it was Mahogany and then there was like
some other people that were there.
None of us were really that,
I mean I probably was like the
hottest, but I was pretty raw. I mean,
I don't know. I think I was cute.
I don't think I was like, uh,
I don't think I was a model and I,
I don't think that was my future.
Maybe I could've done something, but I'm,
the only person that I had really bonded
with was this 23 year old Guy Chris,
who was this black guy from, I dunno
where he was from, but he was really cool.
He was really nice and
he was a little creepy.
Like he would say things
like if I was your age,
but he never was trying
to fuck me or anything,
but he kind of was protecting me and at
some point Mahogany got mad. There was,
it was fake. Like I would just,
he would make me go buy him weed on the
corner and stuff and it's just a fake
thing. My parents paid like $1,500 to
send me to this thing and he would,
I think he sent me out to be a,
I had to go into New York by myself on
the train at 15 wearing the sluttiest
clothes ever to this thing
to, and then he would tell me,
pretend you're lie and say you're 21 to
be an extra on like sex in the city and
stuff. It just wasn't real. There was
nothing real about, it was a total scam.
So I was starting to catch onto that and
I was supposed to be there for maybe 10
days, I think. And they'd, these
next door neighbors, shorty,
this little Puerto Rican lady, she
was away. I smoked blunts with her.
But um, so this guy,
Chris was kind of protected me and he
would go into the city with me and then
all of a sudden mahogany
didn't like how close we were.
So he separated us and he said,
you can't see each other anymore.
And I was like, well, I don't feel
safe if I can't talk to this guy.
Just would rather go home.
I want to call my parents.
I don't think this is real. This
seems like bullshit and a scam.
And he was like, you can't
talk to your parents.
And he locked the door and
took the phone away from him.
So I packed all my shit up and I threw
it out the window and I yelled down to
shorty. I was like, Yo, I'm going to run.
So grabbed my shit. And then the guy,
one of the other kids that was staying
at the modeling place knew the situation.
So he went down and bumped into the door,
unlocked it without him
noticing and distracted him.
And I just jetted out of the fucking
house and he started chasing me.
I was like screaming. I was like,
call the cops, help me, help me.
And I was wearing a tube top.
My like 15 year old titties.
I had nipple rings were like hanging
out. I mean, I looked like a prostitute.
The cops ended up coming and they thought
I was a prostitute. Mahogany got me.
At one point I was hiding
under cars for my life.
Like I thought I was going to
get killed. I was like screaming.
People were just watering their plants.
Like what the fuck on the Lakers cars?
Yeah. Cause he was chasing me.
So I was trying to hide and
he finally got me was like,
get in the hat like you're
ruining my scam pretty much.
And then he scratched
my arm, but that's all.
And then the cops came and arrested.
Both of us thought he was my pimp.
I thought I was a prostitute.
I come from like a,
like a [inaudible] when you came home? Um,
well they came to the cops and then the
cops told them that they should arrest
my parents. They were like, we should.
And I think they just were in denial
about it or whatever for a day at least.
Yeah. They didn't. And then
more stuff happened after that.
They'd made more mistakes. Yeah.
But it's okay. We all make mistakes.
I love my family. They're good now. But
I also look at all these things. No,
I really like have had to do a lot of
work on it because to forgive them. Yeah.
Because, well I blame myself
for all of it, for most of it,
which was my defense mechanism.
Like the stuff I had some stuff happened
with a teacher in high school to him
right after that. Actually it was about
six months after that happened and uh,
you know, was a therapy session. I
don't want to do a therapy session.
I don't want to do that. But anyway,
you had asked me about am I happy about
these things? And so I'm coming to it.
But the point that I'm coming
to is I am happy with them.
I'm so happy with like where my life
is now that I can't be mad about any of
these other things. Do you know
what I mean? Like they're, they're
like exciting and now they're
funny cause I didn't get heard.
That's what I'm saying. Like looking
back on the fucking hilarious. Yeah,
there's some crazy shit.
There's some romance to it if you're
[inaudible] I flashed a chain gang once on
my motor scooter and then it didn't
start and I had to like put my shirt down
and keep bogging it. Like it's hilarious.
I did crazy shit and I came out like
genuinely I feel good, you know,
I'm happy with my life. So it's
good. Thank you for getting that.
Getting me off of that path.
But well it's just everyone that I
know that's funny is fucked up and had
something go wrong. Just that's how,
and it's like how you get through it and
then your insight into it on the other
end you persevere and then
you don't blame people.
You don't let go around being mad at the
world. I think it's, it's easier to be,
um, I don't know. It's just some of the
most hilarious people did blame people.
Yeah. Cause that's Kennison
Kennison was always, you know,
screaming about his ex wives. Yeah, no,
that's true. That's funny too. I just,
for my own personal sanity cannot
run around angry at everyone.
Well you don't need to be,
I mean it's not necessary.
And especially now that you're sober,
which obviously [inaudible] had never got,
he uh, was friends with them? No, no,
never. No, never met him. Saw Him,
saw him live a few times
once, uh, once at work.
Once when I was working I was
working at a great woods, um,
center for the performing arts and it's
like a amphitheater in Mansfield doing
sun fall kicks. No
security. Oh cool. Yeah.
And I got to see Cosby there, Rodney
Dangerfield cause see a few people.
Did you want to do
comedy yet? Um, I was 19.
I probably had thought about it
a little bit. You know, maybe,
maybe it had been in
my head like slightly,
but I didn't really start thinking
about it until I was like 20.
And you feel embarrassed when you had
that thought at first of doing comedy?
No, but I did feel like
it was preposterous.
I did feel like, um, look, it's
such a difficult way to make it.
Like I remember my
girlfriend when I was 21,
her dad was mocking this idea
that I was going to be a comedian.
Like I remember him
saying, well, you know,
the odds were not in your favor.
No, they're not in anybody's favor.
But I remembered that's what he was
saying. You know that like who makes it,
how many people make it as a kid and
even if you do make and how much money do
you make? He was a doctor. That's
so funny. He was really angry.
Like he just felt like I
was a waste of his daughter.
It's really funny cause he's still
alive. Let's get him on the podcast.
It's probably not, you know, doctors
don't live that long. A lot of them died.
That was so, it was sad when he
died. I was like, I trusted you.
Well there's a great book called
dead doctors don't lie, but this guy,
Joel Wallach and what a lot of it has
to do with nutrition and it's about
mineral deficiencies and vitamin
deficiencies and doctors who abuse drugs.
And I'm essentially
talking about how people rely on
doctors for advice about health,
when in reality doctors are
good at very specific things.
Like if you're a podiatrist, you're good
at fixing feet. If you're a, you know,
an orthopedic surgeon, you're good
at knees and shoulders and shit,
but you probably don't know a fuck load
about nutrition and you really don't
understand like the mechanisms of the
body's absorptions of nutrients and
minerals and vitamins.
And one of the things that I've learned
from doing this podcast is to understand
that even like when I, the cursory
understanding of it that I have,
you have to go through fucking hours and
hours and hours of reading and watching
documentaries and listening to experts
and I still have to go back over and over
and over it again.
So I've talked to doctors before and
they'd been like super dismissive about
even taking vitamins and I get
angry at them. I'm like, well,
I think all you need is a balanced
diet. I'm like, well, you're retarded.
Like what are you talking about?
That's it. And by that way,
I don't mean someone with downs syndrome
that is a retarded way in slow down.
You are your, you have a diminished
capacity for advancement.
You are slowing down the reality of
the progress of nutritional science.
This is a stupid thing you're doing
right now and giving me bad advice.
You really don't know what the fuck you're
talking about. I get angry. I'm like,
why would you say that? Like this is dumb.
Don't tell me that there's no benefit to
taking vitamins when there's a fucking
ass load of studies.
There's data and science
and it's all proven.
[inaudible] spent thousands
of hours researching this
stuff and trying to figure
out what the fuck is good for you and
what's not good for you and some Chubby
asshole with a fucking skinny fat body
is telling me that all you need is a
balanced diet. I'm like,
bitch, what's your diet?
You ain't got a balanced diet that
they're just doing that because they don't
get money out of there, out of the
vitamins. No, no. They don't have.
It's not feel like reading up on
the new stuff, but they haven't.
They haven't decided to pursue
it. That's all it is. I mean,
and if they did pursue it,
they'd realize it's a fucking bottomless
pit of information from essential fatty
acids to different kinds of proteins
and absorption of plant based proteins
versus animal based proteins.
What's the benefit of grass
fed beef over regular B?
It's a fucking endless stream of, yeah,
I mean if you follow someone
like Dr Rhonda Patrick,
you realize really quickly that she is
in the heart of this shit 24 hours a day,
seven days a week and she's still
learning things net. It never ends.
It never ends. I mean we,
we, and also it varies.
What's good for you is not
necessarily good for me.
Your Diet might not be as effective
as my Diomede elk cause that bad.
That's good. That's good for
everybody. It is alk all day.
Turn you into a fucking savage. I'll
give you this fucking elk. Give you some,
I got it. I got some waiting for
fanny pack and some Goddamn alk.
That's what kind of a cooking
set up do you have at your place?
I just have just a stove with frying
pan, like cast iron frying pan. I do.
I have to know how to cook. You could
cook. I'm all right. Decent. Okay.
I'm decent. I'll hook you up with some
elk sausage. We'll start with that.
I'll give you a recipe how to cook it
correctly. Do you have a thermometer? Um,
I'm really into, I'm really into,
um, big foot porn. Can you not say
elk sausage in front of me? Yeah.
Um, I don't have a meat thermometer.
No. Well that's good for elk
sausage. It's fine. And you'll,
you'll get a sense of when it's going
to leave. You want want line me? Y, Y,
y n cause I didn't get to a quick, when
you're talking about choke sausage, Bro,
I'm sorry I'm insulting or no, it's
just big foot dick elk sausage.
I don't know why I wouldn't draw those
two. I wouldn't pull those together.
Why you wouldn't, yeah. Why W why would
I not have one of them as a undulate?
The other one is a legendary
primate. Oh my God.
You're ever really getting
stuck in semantics here. Listen,
you're the one who cracked the joke.
Let me just make some fucking jokes.
I just got accused of doing a therapy
session and now I'm telling jokes,
I'm feeling triggered. Are you
feeling judged? No. No, but I'm,
I'm not feeling judged,
but everybody that I know that
has had those wild drunken days,
it has come out on the other sides.
There's something like nostalgic about it.
Like you look back and you go,
Huh, I made it through that.
Have you been to an AA meeting? You can't.
It's like the good old times and AA or
I always felt like people were either
telling these stories that were so
insane. I was like, I'm not an alcoholic.
Or they were like, I was like, let's
put Shit, you know, get outta here.
You don't even cool enough to be
here. Like celebrity rehab. Right.
Did you ever watch that show? One of the
best parts about it was Eric Roberts.
Julia Roberts brothers has
been a bunch of movies. He, uh,
was there for weed addiction. Yeah.
And everybody else was having the fucking
d dts or on the floor in the fetal
position shaking. He's reading
the paper [inaudible] Shit.
Cause on a treadmill, it's so
ridiculous. Like some people,
you know their stories are a joke.
I did quit smoking weed and it did
make things a lot easier, like laundry,
just little things. I was like,
oh that was maybe making things.
I would always smoke weed before I
cleaned my apartment and I was like seven
years to get my apartment. Glenn. Yeah,
it can get distracting. It doesn't,
it does not affect me. Well yeah.
Well when I do things like
if I want to clean my office,
I just have like a thing, like this is
what we're doing now. And I had her all,
even listening to music is not good.
I find that I used to listen to
podcasts while I clean my office,
but then I find that I would be like
pausing and listening to a particular part
and then I'd want to rewind it. I'm
like, Oh, I'm fucking with myself here.
I'm distracting myself. And then
that's a weird defense mechanism too.
Cause I do that all the time too.
I'm always multitasking and I always
have to be doing three things at once.
It's like why? Cause it's gonna make
me, I'm gonna slow down so much.
I might have to like deal with them. Yeah.
So like writing to like sometimes
I write listening to music,
but most of the time it's better
without music. With lyrics. Yeah. Yeah.
Sometimes lyrics and sometimes
foreign music I like foreign music is,
I don't know what they're
saying. What kind Brazilian. Oh.
Like a lot of Brazilian music. I look a
lot of Spanish music, Bollywood or what?
I listen to some of that dollar men
day. Do you know dollar Bandanas? No,
you don't. No dollar now. Oh he's amazing.
It's really cool. I just listened to,
I listened to a lot of Elton John.
That's what I'm into right now.
That's why I like to wear all my
crazy things too. Like to Elton John.
That shit put you some dollar Mindy
here. Play it on my phone. She didn't.
We get banned 100%. 100%. Why it's
gotten before. Even if we have,
cause you can't, how do
you spell his name? D a.
There it is. Dollar Mindy. Um,
what does this say?
The song is not currently available
in your country or region. Oh my God,
I love it. And now I'm really into it
and I want that shit. What is that? Oh,
here it goes.
[inaudible] we can't hear. We can't
hear. We can't hear. We can't hear.
That's actually a woman getting fucked
by big firm. The Guy Yelling. Yes. Wow.
Okay. Welcome to the wonderful
world of the Internet.
Um, anyway, I like dollar Mindy. It
sounds cool, but this is named dollar d a.
H. Hold on. I would like to better
if it was like the [inaudible] l.
E r m e. H. N. D. I,
but I think he got arrested
for human trafficking.
But can you still like his
work? That's a problem.
Like I was at a Dave Chappelle and
I did some shows the other day,
DJ and the DJ was playing all this, uh,
Michael Jackson music
and uh, he is so good.
Yeah, he's great. Go. He's a
fucking pedophile. Allegedly.
Most likely. Yeah, pretty. Probably.
Definitely did something wrong. Yeah.
Even though it's still
fucking great. Yeah.
But also he's dead. Yeah.
So what if you don't listen to
his music, you're punishing?
What are you punishing? Okay. The man's
dead bright. But even if he wasn't dead,
like if Ted Bundy had some great
poetry, would you want to read it?
Would you enjoy it? Um, no. I
don't create it. Probably not.
Yeah, I mean, I don't know. I really
don't know what Michael Jackson did.
I don't know. And I don't think anybody
does other than the snow. He did it too,
but there's a lot of fucking
weirdness to it for sure. Yeah.
Hands with little boys. And I
know it's really uncomfortable,
just like inappropriate boundaries.
And that's enough to like Molesta Kit.
Honestly,
just having that inappropriate listen
blurred thing between kids and grownups.
That's not good. Yeah.
You hold hands with your nieces
and nephews and that makes sense.
Your children, that makes sense.
But if you're a 55 year old man and you're
holding hands with 11 year old boy in
Dubai, yeah, that's where I gotta
get. I gotta get suspicious.
I got a question whether I'm going to
enjoy this song that I'm enjoying right
now. I want to be. It's done. It's
done. It's done. It's so good.
I was listening to the music. I was like,
God damn, this guy was amazing. Yeah.
So except there's no way he wasn't
molested. I mean, it doesn't,
he seem so molested. Well, um,
in the interest of being
beaten a fucking dead horse.
I have talked about this many times in
the podcast where I think that he was a
cast trato,
which is someone who was castrated when
he was very young to preserve his high
pitched voice. Then his doctor,
the same doctor that killed him,
came out later.
This is long after I'd predicted this
and said that he was chemically castrated
to preserve his voice. So he,
he confirmed what I was saying.
Now whether this doctor's
telling the truth is castration.
Are you not able to get a boner?
I don't believe so. Um, oh my God.
So he maybe was him less
than them, but he was just,
he could have been just being
weird with them. I don't know who,
maybe didn't do anything with them.
Maybe he just wanted to be a child.
Maybe his childhood was stripped from him
because he was famous from the time he
was five fucking years old and his
father did something to definitely was a
weird life. According to the doctor, his
d, His father did did something to him,
like chemical castration is
what they do. That pedophiles,
they'll do it to pedophiles so
that they can never get erections.
And it basically stops your body's
production of testosterone and kills your
testes. And they do it with
some, some chemical injection.
And apparently according to the doctor,
that's what they did to Michael Jackson,
which you think about his voice.
It makes sense because his voice
was insane. It was so high pitched.
And if you listen to like ca
Strados, those a, there's,
there's only a few recordings
of actual Chris throttles.
But it was a common practice. Not
Common. Most everybody did it,
but it was a practice that was done to
young boys to preserve their high pitched
voice where they're at fucking cast rate
and what a word, horrible cause strata.
But they did it. I mean,
people would let their children
get their balls chopped off,
can sing good, and they would, you
know, it'd be very valuable too.
How long ago was that? Well, there's
a recording, so the recording,
I don't think they had recordings
until like the late 18 hundreds I don't
believe when there was a lot of dance
dancing last one 1922 1922 is
the last Castrato recording.
And how old was that dude?
So he's probably born in
the 18 hundreds or something
died in that same year. So that's,
but it's, he died. Never
nothing but always. Yeah.
Have you ever heard the voice of an
angel and the, we can't play that either,
right? No. You should listen to it
though. We'll, I'll play it upsetting.
It's upsetting. It is upsetting.
It's haunting. Yeah, you can. Yeah,
you can enjoy that. Yeah.
I played it for a friend of mine the
other night and he was like, what?
And I was like, look, you got to listen
to this. And I played, he's like,
is that fucking real? And he's like,
it sounds like like someone who like did
something to somebody and you're like,
oh,
maybe people show jerk off to it to like
an honor of the man was 63 when he died
in 1922 he was born in
1958 and those recordings,
1851 and 1902 to 1904 so that makes them
forties he was in his forties when you
say Lord knows you said
1958 you mean he was born
in 1858 and 58 when he was born, I'm
sorry. Yeah. And died in 1922 wow.
Yeah, that's the whole thing's dark.
The look you gave me during my circle
jerk idea was [inaudible] we'll look,
I'll you, you gave me a come
on bitch circle jerk for the,
I was saying it to [inaudible] he
couldn't come. Look, you're projecting.
Listen, I know this is uncomfortable
for you and you're nervous to be here,
but I'm your friend and I love you
and I want you to be happy. I'm not
looking at trip. Come up the
king. You know I love you. I know.
I love you too. Thank you so much for
having me. I really do appreciate it.
I am trying to be chill. It's just
like a cool weirded out by this,
by being here. I'm not weirded out.
I'm trying to be in the moment.
I like to be funny impulsively like it's
my impulse to always like tell jokes
and stuff and this is a
more like chill, less jokey.
You could be jokey now
there's pressure to be joking.
You're overthinking this shit.
Too much overthinking anything.
I'm being chill in normal. Everyone.
Two Cups of coffee, cups of coffee.
One's calling me a con. What is a
one of them? One of them is cave man.
What's the other one? This is
caveman and this is a cunt mug.
I got it from my dad and I got one
for myself to got it for your dad.
He has a joke. Well, my dad and I, it
also looks like it says aunt. We one time,
uh, we went to, we were
at the post office.
My Dad's very funny. He reminds me of
caddy. Daddy actually the, Oh, really?
Held down against thing. By the way,
that fucking thing is hilarious that
you guys are doing. It's fun. Yeah.
We recorded one and then, uh,
it just wasn't funny. It wasn't,
we'd have to rethink it.
Don't want to put out,
we don't want to disappoint
with Capitol one.
You did do the one you did put it out
was hilarious. Yeah, that was fun. Yeah.
He's so funny. He's hilarious. But, um,
so my dad and I were at the post office
and mailing something out and I was
taking a while to mail something out and
just were just jokingly antagonistic.
You know, my dad's like, come on. I was
like, Dad, leave me alone. I'm not done.
You know, we're just joking
with each other. Right.
And this old woman who's been observing,
she goes to leave and then she just
pivots before she leaves and turns around.
She goes, she goes, you know what
young lady, you're a real itch,
itch, itch. And my dad goes,
I think he mean an end,
which is fucking one of our
best stories. My Daddy's funny.
So she doesn't realize, you're
just joking around. She didn't get,
we were just joking. She was like,
Oh, you're being sewn. And it's like,
did you tell her, Hey, this is
my dad. We're just joking around.
My Dad said she's an aunt and we
laughed. So I think she got up. Yeah.
Well she was leaving when he said,
yeah, we just worked with like crying.
And the fact that someone really needs
to stump you and put you in your place.
Yeah. It's just so silly, but it's like
she was old. What does she know? Ah,
I'm sure. I'm just going to try really
hard to not be one of those old people.
What do you think you're going to be
like as an old lady? I'm going to peak.
I'm excited. Well, I'm
trying really hard to,
I'm trying really hard to be in the
moment and appreciate each new age and not
get anything in my face
or anything like that.
And just sitting in your face while, you
know, except come shots obviously. No,
I'm in like a, you know?
Oh you, I don't, yeah,
I'll try not to do anything
too crazy. It's just,
it's fighting an inevitable thing. And
I think it's a gift to age. You know,
we get to be different every day.
My mom was a, she worked at, uh,
this organization called Gray Panthers,
which can cause for old people,
old people that like to fuck. I
mean, I'm sure they like to fuck.
But Maggie Kuhn, Maggie
coon was the woman's name,
which I know there's a little bit
of a parallel between gray panthers,
Black Panthers, her last
name is [inaudible], but
it was spelled differently.
Um, but so she was this, it was
in Philadelphia and she was, uh,
she liked [inaudible] was 90, maybe 89,
but we used to hang out with her
all the time. And she had dated,
famously dated like a 40 year old, I
think in her eighties or something hollow.
So I think she was fucking pegging
him. She might've been pegging him.
I don't know if she
could peg at that point.
She had a lot of hats and a lot
of cats down. He could peg. Oh,
he can peg himself.
Remember Elizabeth Taylor?
It was like she married a series of gay
guys before she died. Oh yeah. Yeah.
That happens really pretty
old ladies that you know,
they just want a man to
tell them they're beautiful.
I've been just showered with
compliments by gay men. Yeah.
I think they go through menopause too
and they probably give up on the idea of
sex. They just want pretty
men around them. Yeah.
I mean not that her gays were that
pretty. I've had prettier gays.
I've definitely been the law. I've
been the last post for a couple guys.
The last post before gay.
Yeah. Where I'm like,
and then one guy had got married
and shit. I was sure he was.
I sure I was sure it was his last. Listen,
just because you got married
doesn't mean he's not good. Yeah,
that's a good point. I know.
Did he guys would read gay
men would reach out to him.
They would try to touch him
and he's always wearing a suit.
We lived in Santa Fe. I'm like, where am
I going to suit? Like slap their hands.
I'm like, not until he comes out
here. I knew. I mean I was like,
there's no way. He used to always want
to have like threesomes with other guys.
Like there was always,
I remember we invited my one friend
and we were just drinking so much.
We call it a,
we called Jack Daniels o j so we didn't
feel weird and more like past the OJ,
we're just like fucking
shit faced all the time.
Shuggie [inaudible] went
to this college, what?
My college and I'm going out of business,
just this little school in
Santa Fe just hammered. And uh,
my friend who I worked at a restaurant
with a guy friend, he wanted to hug,
hook up with me and he's like sweet.
So he like hops into bed with us and
then he leaves the next day. He's like,
he kept looking me in the eye
and he kept looking at me.
He kept trying to make eye contact
with me. So he was bone in you and you,
your boyfriend was like, I don't
know if he ended up owning me.
I think he would just, he hopped
in the hopped out pretty quick.
What does that mean? Cause he got
freaked out cause he kept looking at him.
I don't know if it actually, I mean we
were in full black lights at that point.
I don't remember.
I really feel like I'm five years younger
than I am because I just blacked out
five years. You should write about
those days. I don't know. This book,
there were so many.
I have so many crazy stories and it's
funny because I always thought everyone
else had them. I really thought
everyone else had this crate. I'm like,
you didn't steal cars
when you were little.
Like you didn't do all these
things that never happened to you.
Have you thought about writing
a book? Yeah, but that'd be,
it's also a great glide comedy
writing act. Yeah, I know.
I want to tell these stories on stage
to the more flashing. The changing was,
I mean there's just been so many.
I drew some pictures I draw too,
so I've been drawn in a while,
but I drew like a coloring book once
that I never followed through with,
but it was a lesson from a Chubby
alcoholic and it was just different,
like true scenes from my drinking
days. Just fucking crazy.
This shit I did. So how did
you stop? I will tell you,
that actually brings me back to
Tate. So I moved to New York.
I wanted to do standup so bad.
I'd just done that one thing at the
cowgirl in Santa Fe and I liked it.
I really, I was nervous
and I don't remember.
I'm sure it was like all abortion
jokes. I don't really remember.
But then I do remember my
first set after that. Um,
I remember all the beginning ones. So
the first one was when I got to New York,
I moved to New York to do
standup. I crashed my scooter,
so I wanted to move to la.
I had met people out in La and I
thought that was where I wanted to go.
But because I kept drinking
and driving, I was like, oh,
I have a drinking and driving problem.
I have to go somewhere where I can't
drive. So I moved to New York, thank God,
because I think I really,
I think it helped me really push and get
really strong before I came out here.
So I moved to New York. I wanted
to do standup. I was just drinking,
I was partying. I have so many friends
I just met on benders, like random shit.
I was just doing insane
things, day drinking,
just way more drunk
than everyone else. My,
I left my drinking buddies in Santa
Fe and everyone else was kind of like,
what are you up to?
So I was staying on my friend's
couch and I wanted to do stand up.
And so finally she was like, look,
um, let's just go to an open mic.
I'll go with you. And I was like, all
right. So I got all my jokes ready.
We go to an open Mike. Um, I go up,
I dropped my setlist and then I
completely black out. I'm so nervous.
I'm like in this basement at
this place called cake shop. Um,
my friend Caper lamp was the host of it
or was she the host yet? I don't know.
Anyway, I got up on stage
and completely bombed.
Just started yelling at everyone.
I just started yelling at all of these
comics like, fuck you. He pieces a shit.
Like I don't know what happened.
And then I sat down at the bar
and I'd already quit Jaeger.
Jaeger was the first thing I quit.
So I was sitting at the
bar and some guy came up,
this comic who I did not like or think
was funny or want anything to do with,
and he kept buying me drinks. He was
buying me shots of Yeager and I was like,
look man, I'm like struggling
with drinking. I really like,
I can't really say no to a drink,
but please stop buying them from me.
And he just kept buying them like I just
was, you know, I wasn't going to stop.
And so he kept buying them.
And then so then I ended up
waking up on his air mattress.
Is that for my first [inaudible], waking
up his air mattress fully clothed.
That didn't fuck him or anything.
Just like trap somewhere in Bushwick.
It was snowing. I was like,
where am I? What am I doing?
I looked around his apartment. I'm
like, all I want to do is be a comedian.
I was so sure that's what I wanted to do.
I was spending all this time drinking,
getting fucked out. Second
set. This was my second. Yeah.
This was what I had moved to New
York was my first one in New York.
What made you so sure that
you wanted to be a comedian?
I just never wanted to do
anything else. And when I think,
but you only had one set at a karaoke
bar and then the second set where you
screamed and told everybody to fuck off.
What was it that made you think that you
could do it? Um, I just, I don't know.
I just never wanted to do anything
else. I just didn't have another,
there was no other plan. I
had been a special ed teacher.
I had done a Gogo dance. I'd worked
at the bars, I'd done all that stuff.
I just never, I just always, I just felt
like if I could do it, I could do it.
I mean, I guess it's that little bit
of that delusion and that, but I just,
I never, but I knew that
I wouldn't be able to do,
I knew there were obstacles in my way
and I knew that drinking was one of them.
I had talked to a comic before, uh, that
sat at the open mic and he had said,
just try not to, his advice to me
was try not to hook up with the,
with the guys that open my ex because
you're gonna get a reputation when you're
just trying to be respected.
So he had said that to me.
I think it was great advice because
it's also, there is no time for that.
This was my whole hustle also.
What are the odds that person's going
to fall through a few fall through and
become a comic? What are the
odds that they are? Yeah,
you might get hitched up to
some fucking loser. Yeah.
You definitely don't want to
get hit shot. But it also was,
I needed to put all my energy.
I was in an m s barely in a place now
to be in a relationship. So it's like,
this was 11 years ago. So I, um, I,
I, when I woke up on that guys
air mattress, I was like, fuck.
Like I already broke the thing that I
wanted to do and I was already, you know,
from all my, like weird sexual
assault stuff when I was younger.
I just didn't have a good relationship
with sex. Drinking, didn't help with it,
you know, everything was
just out of control and all,
and I had this thing now this like
precious thing that I want so bad. So,
you know, crashing my scooter,
almost dying all that shit. Nah,
it wasn't enough, but stand up
really was, that's what I wanted.
So I went to my friend's
house and I called Tate,
I just called [inaudible].
I was like, I got to,
I just want to do this and
I want to quit drinking.
And so he told me to go to
meetings and just cha try it out.
Do you remember your first
meeting? Yeah, I went to one,
I think it was the lower east side
and the guy sharing was talking about,
he's like, I always knew I had a
problem because I, I, when I was two,
I took all of the Tylenol and I was
like, what are you talking about?
Any kid with a childproof thing
is just gonna eat the pills.
I remember kind of judging
him and being like, whatever.
But it was good to have that community
then because I needed to detach myself
from like the partiers and all
that lifestyle. So I did go to,
I did 1998 at a meeting every day for
90 days and then I never went back.
Some people actually learn how to
do stand up from those meetings.
There was a gun, I mean, not a bomb.
There was a guy named Dave Fitzgerald
who was a really funny comedian back in
Boston and um,
he learned how to do stand up from
making hilarious stories out of his drunk
days cause he, he was a fucking
raging alcohol. The same thing,
just quit and then started
doing, stand up and literally
learned how to do a family meeting.
Cause he would tell these crazy
stories about being blacked out,
drunk and fucked up and being
at gun fights, you know,
high speed chases and all this nuts had
alcohol to shed. Crazy stuff goes down.
Yeah. But those guys, many of
them learn how to do stand up.
You're standing up in front of an
audience. I was brought up Quaker too,
so our church was,
you stand up and speak and everyone just
sits there in silence and watches it.
Yeah. What's that like? Which
one's Quaker? That's the oats box.
[inaudible] box. Everyone's
like gets a confused with Amish,
which has nothing to do
with Amish. The difference.
It's just a very chill Christianity. So
it's, those are the pilgrims. The fist.
Quakers. No, I don't think they were.
They were, um, when do Quakers and start,
I don't ask sophists.
They're, they're pacifists.
They believe that God's in the form of
an inner light that's in everyone and
everything. So why would you fight?
I mean I agree with that just from
hallucinogen and shit too. But, um,
it's something I struggle with. Like
I have to look back at, you know,
childhood predators and I'm like, can I,
I have to forgive these people because
they are from the same light. I guess.
What is the, what's the
wacky thing Quakers? Quakers
are, well, it's just very,
it's just, you sit in silence. So
the churches, there's two types.
There's programmed and
unprogrammed I was unprogrammed,
which is the super chill one. There's
no bible talk. There's no preacher.
There's nothing. You just sit
in benches facing each other.
My meeting house had these old creaky
explain. What are you talking about?
So it's like a, it's a meeting house that
you meet up with the onset on Sundays.
Yeah. You look down at your hands, you
don't really look at each other, but you,
you sit, there's facing benches and
then there's, you know, benches here.
So you are kind of all looking
at it. You're facing each other.
And what do you do? You sit in silence
and then if you feel moved to speak,
it's supposed to be God speaking to you,
but if you just feel
moved to speak at all,
you just stand up and you
say whatever you want. Wow.
And so you don't reading
scripture. I mean, some people,
every once in a while someone
would do that. Growing up,
I went to a Quaker school
too, and we were little kids.
We used to have to sit in silence for
like 45 minutes, which was impossible.
It's such bad 80 dude. It was insane.
I would wear shirts that had like
things on it. I could play with.
Like I had a shirt with a phone and it
had like a cord and I would just wear it
and I would set alarms and set on
my alarm so it wouldn't go off.
I just had to be doing
stuff. It was crazy.
You're just so little and you're just
sitting there. So bored. Little incense,
so bored, you know? And what's
the first thing they do?
They try to medicate them
because they're so bored. Well,
I got medicated to
Ritalin and stuff. Oh No.
But when I was older, I don't
feel like it affected me.
They put me on
antidepressants a little bit,
but I was pretty good at being like,
I don't want to do these things.
Don't feel like it affected
you to be why stolen.
But I didn't take it for that long.
How long did it take it for? I Dunno.
I don't think I took it for
that. Allie Makowski Duh.
She was talking about it last
night. I love her. Love her too.
She was telling us about how that same
shit happened to her when she was kid.
Yeah. Bouncing off the walls and
the Medicaid you, yeah. It's so,
it is interesting cause it is. I can only
imagine what it's like to be a parent.
You just, there's all this
information coming at you and you're
dealing with your own shit.
And a lot of people didn't go through
their healing process or anything to,
it's, it must be so hard to be a
parent. It's just gotta be crazy.
I think about it.
I never wanted to have a kid until I did
some hallucinogens and then I was like,
maybe I want to have a kid. You'd be
a great mom. Yeah, I think I would,
but I'm just dealing with all my
heel. I'm dealing with all my,
I just want to make
sure I'm not in a place.
I was very angry in the past and
it's something that I work on a lot.
I just wouldn't want to redo
patterns and stuff like that.
But I do think because I've had, I had
such traumatic stuff, I think I would be,
I think I could protect
my kids in a good way.
And Quakers are allowed to medicate their
kids. It's part of the doctrine. Yeah,
you can, there's no dye.
I mean it's pretty loose.
It's like you can do whatever you want.
There was one guy that wore his
like Jewish stuff to a meeting. Uh,
well I went to meeting after the
election. I want a little bit. I was like,
maybe I want to go back to the
church. The Quaker church. Yeah.
I just feel doesn't 16
yeah. Cause I just was,
it just triggered a lot of
things in me and, and uh,
I went real crazy for a second.
I just had a lot of trauma that I wasn't
dealing when Trump won. It wasn't,
this is embarrassing. Okay. I was
hanging out with a lot of, anyway,
what happened? I just got really
like, I got really mad. I don't know,
I got really mad. I just
wasn't, I wasn't um,
dealing with stuff and it just kind of
pushed all this stuff forward for me.
And also, what do you mean?
But just like some sexual
assault stuff just came up.
Like I think a lot of people that were
angry and were marching around and stuff
were,
had some personal triggers that had
happened for them because of like the grab
them by the Pussy and then you read it
and then I read up on it and it's not
what it seems. And I don't
know, I just, I, you know,
there was a lot of hysteria
and it just trigger,
it just triggered a lot of my shit.
But I'm glad it did because it
helped me get through a lot of stuff.
And I definitely,
I think have a different view on
those things now. And I, you know,
I was running around so mad at who I'm
like, who am I mad at? I did a lot of,
like, when it first happened,
I was like, fuck man,
I did that for about three months.
Thank God I got out of that.
But really angry and just projecting
and pissed and all this stuff.
And it's like, there's a few, there's a
few men, I'm at it right. There's a few,
I'm certainly not mad at men, but
there are a few from your past. Yeah.
You know,
and that was something I had to deal with
and I had to learn to compartmentalize
that and not make it this broad
thing. I hate when people do that.
So upsetting the drinking days, the
drinking days, and from my childhood,
you know, I had, I had some fucked up,
shit happened. But you know, it, it's,
you can't, it's just important to,
for me to not blame a large group of
people that have nothing to do with my
trauma. And it's also
when I get triggered,
what I needed to learn was that's my
responsibility to handle my trigger.
And I can't just be running around like
this, like unsheathed sword. I mean,
I can, I'm going to
cut everyone around me.
You're the thing that people do when
they blame everyone that's part of that
group. You know, it's so common and
it's so, you remember, uh, there
was a real problem a few months
back where Liam Neeson, uh,
was talking about one of his friends
that had gotten something that happened
where, uh, a black, I had done something
murdered. One of his friends are raped,
one of his friends, something
awful. I think it was great.
And so he would go out at night with
a bat looking for a black guy to start
trouble. And he talked about,
and everybody was furious
at him and he's saying,
look, look, I didn't do anything and
I was in a terrible state of mind.
I'm just being honest about
this. I'm not proud of this.
It was one of the most embarrassing
and darkest moments of my life,
but I did it right.
And not letting people express those
things and talk about it and say a wet
cause. I am embarrassed that I got so
man hideous. I mean it's, you know,
there's a couple of podcasts I did where
I was like, fuck man. You know, and I,
that hurts people. I hurt
people by saying that. Well,
I mean it's still whatever. No,
but people have lashed out
at me for stuff like that,
but it's like I don't fucking,
I don't have the capacity to hate an
entire group of people. And I certainly,
like I have brothers, I have my
dad. I don't, don't use any of this.
Sometimes you say things and that's
not really what you mean. Yeah.
And then expressing anger of course. And
then I think right now what's going on?
And I've checked out of a lot of stuff.
I don't pay attention to a lot of things
anymore cause it was just like the news
you mean? Yeah. It's just like not,
it's not real. I don't read Twitter.
I don't, I just don't do it.
It's like I got to focus on what I can
do and how I can feel good and how I can,
I just want to make people laugh, have
a good time, make people feel good.
I want to feel good.
It's like I can't do that if I'm in this
constant state of taking in all this
information that's just pushing my
buttons, pushing my buttons. Well, yeah,
some of it's not going to be, but
someone certainly is. And you,
if you're not controlling the,
like you have a mental diet too.
And that's something that people
don't think of all the time. You know?
I don't remember who, who
described it that way,
but it's the best way of describing it.
You have a physical diet and if you have
a poor physical diet, your body's sick.
But if you have a poor mental
diet, your mind is sick. Yeah,
you're taking a nonsense all
the time and fights. You know,
I had Bernie Sanders on yesterday and
that guy who was running for something,
my dad. Yeah, a little
bit cool. Um, and uh,
I briefly looked into the comments of uh,
one of the posts and so many fucking
people are so God damn toxic.
Yup.
They're just battling it out left and
right and misrepresenting his position and
misrep someone was calling me and
all right. White supremacists.
White nationalists. Like what in
the fuck. That's so high scent.
I am at tee shirt. So this has,
someone said that I had someone,
what is this storm front
or something like that?
What does that white supremacist page
storm in front of something they said I
had the founder of Stormfront and my
potluck. The fuck are you talking about?
You're just making it up
properly? No proud of those guys.
I had Gavin McGiven Gavin who is
the founder of the proud boys.
I had him on before, but I had him on
before. There was a proud boys. I didn't
even know what the fuck.
Why can't you talk to him?
I asked him about it and I was critical.
I was criticizing him. I was like,
you can't just claim you're going
to have violence with people.
It's so fucking dumb. And
then all the proud boys,
shit that happened with
violence came far after that.
But people were like blaming
me for having him on.
I don't even know what the fuck it
is. He's the Co founder of Vice.
That's what I knew. It
just, it's also interesting.
Don't you want to hear the other side?
Like don't want to hear everyone's
opinions and everyone's thoughts when you
want to try to understand
and come to a common ground.
Don't you want to realize like I'm
not religious really or anything,
but it's like we are all God's children.
Like there's missing this whole thing.
It's this fight against each
other. Yes. But no. Okay.
The problem is there's a lot of these
people that do go on shows and try to
reinvent themselves disingenuous way,
and they try to whitewash what they're
doing and whitewash their past.
And to that point,
I mean the idea is that you're
helping them recruit people.
Before he was on my podcast
though there was no record,
there was no people for him to recruit
to is that people need to understand like
he wasn't,
there was nothing like I had a mom because
he was this guy who was funny and he
used to do a lot of interesting videos.
He fucked up when he started that group
and he fucked up when he was calling for
violence and telling people to choke a
bitch and punch people and grab these
people. And he was doing it in response
to the violence that Antifa was,
was pushing on right-wing people that
would have these meetings and they would
show up. Yeah. Doing like this
all clown mirror back at them.
It's all crazy area was
all poorly thought out.
But the idea that that makes you a
white nationalist cause you talk to,
you talk to them. Yeah.
It's so fucking stupid.
But it's like this is the world we
live in and everything's so polarized.
It's like your left or right. You're
black or white, you're one or zero.
It's like there's no gray
area with the August freeze.
You and the one moment that you said
the thing and then there's no before or
after, there's no growth, there's nothing.
It's like, yeah, fucking out. Yeah.
They just look for this quote
trap and just that's it.
You said that you said that. I'm like
no Mike, I clarified, I expanded,
I took it back.
I revisited it like there's a lot of
things that people do when you talk or you
just, you know, you say things like,
you say things like you don't even know
what the fuck you're going to say when
you're saying it and then you
go, that doesn't make sense.
Then you re re clarify and when you're
talking a long foreign conversation and
like this in a podcast and someone wants
to take a snippet out of it and I just
decided that's who you are. It's nuts.
It doesn't make any sense. And it's,
this is the world we're living in today.
Everybody wants to paint
everyone as toxic. Yeah.
Everyone that you want to paint.
So many people, I should say,
want to paint people as being
a problem or a negative thing,
and it's like this is the Twitter world
where 20% of the people make 80% of the
posts. So many of them are fucking
losers and just also it's such a,
you're giving all of your
power out to outward.
You're not paying attention to
yourself, blaming others. You're
trying to change the world around you.
You're trying to create a safe space
through other people. Yeah. It's like,
do you know unhappy?
You're going to be in your life if you're
expecting other people to come cower
to all of your demands
and do all of your stuff.
Everyone's dealing with their own fucking,
they're not trying to be
happy. Part of it. What's,
what they're trying to do is somehow or
another score points and rack up was,
you know, and,
and distract themselves from their own
life by focusing on these external issues
that they think are critical
and super important.
And some of them are obviously
running for president.
Whoever's going to be presidents, very
important issue. And most of the time,
like 95% of time I avoid comments,
but for whatever reason I
just found myself flipping
through it because I wanted
to see what the people think about Bernie.
Yeah. I'm like, oh, what a mistake.
You can't look, you can't
love. It seems worse though.
It seems like every time I check if I,
if I don't check Twitter for four months
and then I check it, it's like Whoa,
it was, things accelerated this much.
Or people are so angry at so many
different things and just they,
they paint people in such character
caricature like AOC and the,
she is a woman who I don't think they're,
I don't think I've ever seen anybody work.
So people work so hard to mischaracterize
her or paint her in a horrible light.
And I'm like, look, she says
things that I don't agree with.
Why is everyone so fucking
angry? Like what is this?
Well people were put all their thing on
things, on, you know, and those are the,
they have these beliefs. And like
definitely when I was in my whole like,
you know, when I was extra angry
and feeling, you know, you,
you have this whole system
around you and you, you know,
you can't hear the other side
and you have to like, yes,
everyone has to be a
villain in that are they?
They're either with you or
against you. And I dunno,
it's just to me is just
unhealthy. I had to tap out,
I stopped paying attention to a lot of
stuff and I don't know if that makes me
ignorant. I just got to live a happy life.
No, I don't think it does make you angry.
I don't think it's an effective way to
communicate. I think it's a really piss,
poor way to communicate. And I think
it, it fosters rage more than anything.
Yeah.
There's something about being able to
talk to people where you don't have social
cues, you don't have empathy,
you're not looking at them
and people say the meanest,
nasty shit each other and
it's insulting people.
And dunking on people is
more important than actual,
well, it's attention
to, so it's, you know,
they're maybe trying to impress their
other buddies that are on there.
They're trying to get those extra
little likes right there. Like the,
the main point would be they want
to get your attention. Holy Shit,
they got Joe Rogan's attention.
That's so cool. You know,
they just want to feel alive or
whatever. And that's, you know,
people have their own processes. I
tried to not take anything personally.
It's like you don't know me if you
don't like me. Like that's weird.
You don't know me. You shouldn't
really have that much of an opinion.
It's like not finding your validation.
You can't find the good stuff or the
bad stuff in the comments. You can't,
what's, if you're looking at
the comments for good things,
it's just as bad as
looking for bad things.
Yeah. I mean,
some people think it's a good idea to
gauge like whether or not the conversation
was effective or not.
You could have done something better than
navigate it more efficiently or more.
Um, more entertaining for the,
make it more entertaining for
the people that are listening,
looking for the constructive
criticism. Yeah.
I mean there can be some
of that from some people.
The problem is you're trying to
manage all this data at scale, right.
You're dealing with thousands
and thousands of humans
that are charming in and a
lot of them are deeply unhappy. Yeah.
A lot of people that are commenting on
things that are just really frustrated
with their lives.
Like imagine if someone saw or
listened to you when you were like,
fuck man. [inaudible] and they're
like, oh, that's who she is. Exactly.
Then you see, they see you on here
laughing and being silly. Like,
wait a minute. Who is this bitch?
Yeah. Like that doesn't make any sense.
That's not the same person. Yeah.
Well, you're not the same person.
You're not the same person
who you were six months ago.
I know we grow in. Yeah, I would
fully, yeah, I hope so. I mean, I do.
I tried to do a lot of work on
myself. Um, I stopped watching,
watching this was huge for me. I was
watching a lot of true crime. Oh Jesus.
I was watching like
dateline, stuff like that.
All these things and I
mean that is fucking toxic.
People are obsessed with it.
They're obsessed with it. And
I just started to realize,
I know a friend of mine had,
there was one about her sister and once
I saw that and I just realized like this
is not good.
This is finding entertainment out of these
really real things that have happened
to people in this pain and I have
had fucked up. Things happen.
I've had friends have fucked up,
things happen. I've seen these things.
I don't need to bring
awareness to this. I know that.
And I'm not a women get
into those true crime shows.
It's like traumatic and everything,
but it's not, it's, it's real.
These are real things
that happened. Right?
But is it because you want to know that
that's out there so you can prepare
yourself or so you can
be aware like what is,
what is the appeal cause a
apparently c f find out this is true,
but I remember reading this,
that true crime shows sort of
skew in their demographics, um,
more female than male.
Like the more females are into
true crime shows than male.
Yeah, I dunno. I just, I think it's like
a beginning, middle and end to a story.
Like there's a whole plot line and then
they catch the person and the way the
editing is, and they don't have
the interviews and well, for a lot,
a lot of the episodes they will,
sometimes they catch them before they
kill them and that's disappointing. But,
um, it's just very
young women are the biggest true
crime buffs. And here's why.
If you're even remotely interested in
true crime story O in true crime, boy
[inaudible] have the last couple
of years been good to you.
First there was the mega hit podcast
serial, which launched October, 2014,
several months later, the HB HBO re
released the Genx six episode documentary,
Blah, blah, blah, blah, blah,
blah, blah, captivating. Um,
as captivating as the programs
were for the general public,
one group in particular has become
particularly enthusiastic about the genre.
Young women. Hmm.
It's weird and a lot of the victims
are young women. It's like, well,
I don't know what it is. Hmm.
I don't know what sort of,
we'll get it. According
to Dr. Howard Foreman,
a forensic psychiatrist at
Montefiore Medical Center,
the trend is rooted in empathy.
By the time you get to adulthood,
women are able to empathize with a
greater degree than men. On average.
Foreman tells tech inside of this may
lead to true crime being more interesting
to women than men,
simply because if you
empathize more with the victim,
it may be more relevant
to you and more gripping.
Hmm. And then if you empathize with
the murderer or you're in some trouble.
Yeah. Like, Oh, you did a good
job. It just was too, I don't know.
It just got so dark and weird
and yeah, I had a guy in my,
when I was living with my
ex boyfriend in this hood,
in this a apartment building,
there was this really weird kid who was
so overly familiar and just really weird
with me and I felt, I really
felt threatened by him.
I felt really uncomfortable with
him. I told the landlord, you know,
my boyfriend was traveling a lot for
work and stuff, so I was alone a lot.
I had a bat, he was like maybe
18. And he was young written by,
he just was weird. He was off
Asperger's. He very weird, like very,
just the way he looked at me was weird.
He overly complimented me
in an inappropriate way.
I would set up boundaries.
He would keep coming. He tried to,
I was bringing my laundry
up to my apartment and, um,
my boyfriend was out of town and he,
the kid lived at on a different
floor than me. And he goes, Oh,
let me take your laundry. I go, no, no.
And he goes, Oh, let me take it. I go,
no, I'm, I don't need your
help. Very clear. And then he,
the door opens to the elevator. He
tries to take my laundry. I go, no.
And then I get off the elevator and I
start walking and he starts following me
and I go, you don't live on
this floor. And he goes, oh,
sometimes I get off here and
walk up. I go, no you don't.
You're not supposed to be on this floor.
And then I pretended to go into someone
else's apartment cause I couldn't let
him know where I lived. And then he left.
So that's when I called Tate again
and he sat me up with Scott Epstein,
a 10th planet. And that's when I'd been
started doing Jujitsu. Cause I'm like,
nobody's fucking with me anymore. There's
no, I can not control my surroundings.
I cannot control that. All I
can do is control my ability.
Same building, Ma. Jesus Christ. Yeah.
That's the thing that
women have to deal with.
And I have experienced it to a far lesser
degree with creepy dudes who want to
follow me in hotels.
Oh yeah, you have. I've seen people.
People are so weird with you. Yeah,
it's weird. They want to follow
you in hotels though. Yeah. Look,
guys follow me into the elevator and
want to come to my room like, hey, yeah,
they want to watch you jerk off.
I'll do me. Please leave me alone.
Once I'm near them. They
just to stay close people.
People come up to you and
they're so, I'm excited.
This is their moment. They're,
they're shivering. They're shaking.
I watch it all the time. It's,
I told you I want to do a reaction
or they just should have our faces.
Your friends faces when people are
approaching you, we're just all like,
oh my God. I mean they do it on a, a
smaller scale with other people too,
but I'm hitting you really have
it there. Unfolding a paper.
They've always got something
they need to share with you.
Like this is their big chance to tell
you whatever the thing is that they need
to tell you. I mean, it
is really their moment.
You're a part of people's biggest
moment of their life all day long.
The biggest one is when
they have a business pitch,
the most frustrated Sienna.
And I'm like, listen,
we are not going into business together.
How do you know if you don't hear it?
Cause I don't have time to
do what I'm doing already.
And I have a friend party
selling fanny packs.
I can't do more super busy with fanny
pack business higher primate.com so they
brought your fanny pack.
I died when you told me you sell
at Vandy packs out so funny.
Every month I have to keep restocking.
I'm really king, I don't even get it.
I sell a lot of fucking fanny packs.
They sell like crazy but
they're really high quality.
I was living out of my
car when you told me that.
It's a company called roots from Canada.
They make them super high quality leather
and I just get them to print it with
the high higher primate logo on them.
But you know how I found out about this
company and they're excellent fanny
packs that involve anal sex. No dice
clay. Oh my God guys. Clay. How to say,
John. And I said, where did you get
that glorious fanny baggers? Like, oh,
you like it. [inaudible] and uh,
he showed it to me and I said,
this is fucking excellent. It's roots.
There's nothing in there, but you know,
they're showing good. His keys.
Chapstick. Yeah, it's a CVD. Chopstick.
[inaudible] that's the only one I
fuck with. I took some before I came,
so I didn't freak the fuck out. Just to
help you. Oh, there's something in here.
Okay. So rich show yourself ranch.
I was living in my car next to
parking next to one of your cars.
That's it right there.
See that roots fanny pack?
That's where I learned
about it. Oh my God.
Got The fucking beautiful fanny
pack. What makes yours yours?
Well, I bought it from the roots company.
I had them produce them for me and
it's hard to see because it's Kinda,
this is an older one. That's why
I've had this one for a few years.
But there's the higher
primate logo that's in Boston.
The M can you get one
that says Annie Fanny? No,
but you can make it gel. Bring it
somewhere. [inaudible] some money,
some money to make my fanny bag
glitter on it. It's a, yeah,
she'd do it like a craft thing. Like
that'd be fun. Should we have a cra? Yeah,
we'll do a little craft show
that's not hard to puffy paints.
Just do it with glue. You paint it with
glue and then you sprinkles, you know,
a glitter all over it. The glue will
stick to Glidden. Very glittery.
Yeah. There you go. I don't think
so. I try very hard though, Dude.
That's a good look for you.
I'm trying to Elton John and I watched
this video of Elton John Live all the
time at, what are you
showing me, Jamie guys?
The trend of wearing them on up here.
Those people are cowards. No, no,
no, no, no, no, no, no, no,
no, no, no. They are cowards.
They don't want to wear
it as a fanny pack.
So they wear it over their shoulder
because they're cowards and if a hot girl
comes, it doesn't like fanny packs.
They can throw their elbow into it
and pretend they're injured. No,
that's not what they're doing. So sling.
They're doing it because
they don't want, they want
the functionality of a fanny pack,
but they don't want the social stigma.
They're counting,
well, it's a new, yeah, it's like
the Jaden Smith. Jaden, I don't know.
It's like he would wear that
wedding. It's the younger,
this is the younger generation.
They're re they've taken our fanny packs
and they've made them into something
else.
Non-Binary maybe. What is it saying
at the bottom of that picture with
any pack and see through
Iridescent Zip. Okay. Fuck.
Don't have a see-through bag, by the
way. Nobody wants to see your tampons.
Hers maybe. I don't know. You never
know what these young boys, these days,
they're very woke.
Whoa, they're so polite.
But there's all these women that
want to get choked by bigfoot. So
I was reading this thing about Yale and
that Yale put tampons in the men's room
because they said, not
everyone who menstruates is
a woman. And I'm like, yeah,
yes they are. I thought maybe
they worked for diarrhea. Yes.
Everyone who bends straight
is a woman. Scientifically,
we're getting [inaudible] women right
now. Can you tell them wacky? Yeah, it is.
It is a weird thing that's happening.
Oh my, Oh, anyone. Whatever they want.
It's just a weird, yeah, I will too.
I have no problem. I wa I would,
I would love to make you happy. It's
as long as it doesn't, it's so wacky.
We'll Chappelle said that thing on
his special where he said, uh, um,
to what degree do I have to
partake in your self esteem?
Right. That's a good way of looking
at it. Yeah. Yeah. I mean it's,
but it's not just that,
it's, it's an enforcement.
There's like an authoritarian enforcement
of certain language and certain ways
of communicating with people. You know,
there is a Goddamn hilarious thing
that Tim Poole posted up of a communist
meeting where this woman is calling
everyone comrades and this guy is like,
it could everyone please stop moving
because could you guys please stop moving
because I have severe ADHD and all
this moving is really distracting me.
And the woman goes, all right,
thank you comrade. Duly noted.
And then the guy goes, please, can
you stop using gendered language?
When you say that,
in my view it's very
offensive and like it is woke.
God,
this is what I was saying before about
how it's like if you're expecting the
world to accommodate to you, like your
safe spaces inside yourself, you fall,
it's inside you. You don't have
control of the outside world.
This is people trying to control the
language of everyone around them and then
saying it's unsafe. If they
don't follow your new vocabulary,
that's an unfair thing to find
it and you're unfulfilled.
I'm looking an Asian lady and he said,
this can't be real. I'm going to find it.
It's like two days ago he put it me,
Sam Harris reminded me of it as we
were fucking howling laughing about it.
It's just done. It's like parody.
It's like the onion is
not ridiculous enough.
Like these people are more ridiculous
than the most ridiculous parody.
Like you can even mock it,
but do you think that
it is them trying to see
what they can get away with? Yes.
They're a little kid. How far can I go?
They're playing, make believe they're
there. I'm, I'm a chicken. You know,
I'm someone who is, someone said this
to me, I can't remember what it was,
but that all of the words,
the keywords that people are using
now like triggered safe spaces,
they're autistic terms,
they're terms that people use with
autistic children here. This play this.
If we want to defeat capitalism,
we are going to need a party that will
organize working people to fight for the
demands that we want and to win
socialism. Thank you so much. Great.
Yeah, it's quite a privilege. Quick
credit, personal privilege guys.
First of all, James Jackson's
Sacramento, he him. I just want to say,
can we please keep the chatter to a
minimum? I'm one of the people who's very,
very prone to sensory overload.
There's a lot of whispering
and chatter going on.
It's making it very difficult
for me to focus. I know it's,
we're all fresh and ready to go by.
Can we please just keep
the chatter to a minimum?
It's affecting my ability
to focus. Thank you.
Thank you, comrade. What is this?
Okay. Is there a speaker against name,
Chapter Pronouns? Point of
personal privilege? Yes.
Please do not use gendered
language to, to address everyone.
Okay, what did you a red
headed monster. Where is he?
Right in the lower right hand corner
with the Halter top whatever tank top
thing. See that? That would the
redhead red hair crazy right here.
That's the one that jumped up.
That's the he him. She her red.
So he's wearing that red.
So when he gets his period,
do not use gendered language. This is,
this is where we're at. We're at,
we're in nonsense land and people
are acting like this is normal.
You're a bunch of babies. What are
you give a fuck if someone says, guys,
who cares? The Bible said about saying
girls say girls, I could be there.
Say Girls, I don't care.
This is your, you're crazy.
Please do not use gendered language.
What? How does that change anything?
And by the way, you can,
if you can't deal with a bunch of people
moving around and distract and making
noises and shit, just stop.
Get the fuck out of there.
You guys force everybody else to deal
with your fucking weak mind. Go home.
Just watch this on youtube. Eat a steak,
do some squats, steak, eat some elk,
get your fucking life in Norfolk.
Pipsqueak go fuck a Goddamn bigfoot.
Go right a big foot fuck book and make
millions. What is this seminar about?
About being an asshole?
Communism. Socialism.
So it's like playing on this
thing to where it's like,
I want people to feel good.
I was a special ed teacher.
I've done all these things.
Special Ed kids wouldn't
have been talking like this,
asking for all these things and thought
this is what the with these kids are
calling socialism, right?
Like this is what I mean.
Everyone has to be like super,
super sensitive and aware of every
single fucking thing they do.
And every single fucking thing
that everybody around them does.
Everybody seems to comply.
And it makes you a victim too because
it's impossible for that to happen.
So no one's ever going to
comply to everything you say.
There's always going to be one person,
even if they don't even, they want to.
Maybe they were listening to something
else and they didn't know that that's
what they were supposed to do or whatever.
So then there's always going to be,
you're always gonna be
a victim of something.
Someone's always said the wrong thing.
They've always done the wrong thing.
And all of your worth is from something
outside of yourself and you now don't
have to deal with your own. It ramps up.
What used to be acceptable year ago
now is unacceptable. A year from now,
it'll be something else. After a while,
you won't even be able to say colored.
You're going to have to say
the C-word, right? Yeah.
You have to say you can't say
people of Color, which is PSE.
Just that people of color.
That is a weird one. Yeah.
Like the NCAA or um, NAACP,
brother National Association for
the advancement of Colored People,
which is bananas. Like you can't say
that. You can't even say that anymore.
It's like so dumb. It's a
jewelry thing. And also people,
I feel like if people stopped having
attachment towards you could stop having
them mean anything. Like
they wouldn't hurt you.
While the winter news talked about that
in the 60s it was one of his bits in the
60s he would, he would call people by
a bunch of ethnic slurs and then say,
you know,
the problem with not saying these words
is that if you say these words enough
time, they lose all their meaning and
there's not going to hurt some feelings.
I'm paraphrasing, but this is
the opposite and you know what?
This is nothing. They turn him
into a woman and Ms. May is a,
Oh they rerouted that. They rebooted
him. I've watched a little bit.
I think it's good.
I haven't watched 'em but it is
Marshall that Mrs Maizel has him. Yeah,
she's the mother audition for that. And
then when I saw her tits in the front,
I'm like my tits audition for her. Ted's,
that's like amazing show, you know.
But in the first scene she showed her
tits. I was like, all right, thank you.
Thank you for getting me that audition.
I don't understand what you're saying.
She showed her tits in the first scene
and I didn't realize that that was going
to be in the scene. They didn't
make me go topless or whatever,
but I was honored to have been
in the same audition pool is,
oh, okay. This is Rachel Brosnahan
juice. Sheila's great. She looks great.
She's got it. She's a great
actress. She is hilarious.
But I was talking to a male comic. It
was really funny and he was like, ah,
I don't like that fucking show. Because
there was no woman like that back then.
Yeah. There was no superman either, man.
Like with the [inaudible] talk
about there's no walking dead.
Rick didn't kill any zombies.
Guess what? It's all fake. Yeah,
he's a really freak you out. There was
a woman comic like they're about comedy.
So funny show about comedy.
You should be excited that there's a show
about standup comedy in the 1950s and
sixties it's fucking great. Like so what
do you care if they made up a woman?
Like why? Well, they're not
getting represented. The white men.
It's not even that. It's like, it's
like a historical thing. Yeah, it would.
[inaudible] was bothering
him historically. They are,
they are intersecting with
real things that happened,
so I can see where
that's a little annoying.
I don't wanna bring up Elton John Again,
but I did see rocket man in it. It is.
It was weird when they were not, if
there are things that happened in your,
why do you say bring up
Elton John Again? Yeah.
You just didn't even bring him up earlier.
I've just been talking about him
the whole time. Did she know,
I listen to Elton John
a lot. Did you? Yeah,
I watched this one live video of him a
lot. I don't think you said they were,
it did. Did you? Yeah,
I forgot. That's okay.
I can only be expected to be
listened to 20% of the time.
What was wrong with rocket mare? Well,
it's just, he didn't write the lyrics,
which they said,
but then the whole movie was like trying
to force these life events into the
lyrics. So it was like, but he didn't
write it so he didn't write it.
So it just wasn't, it didn't feel real.
I would have rather have heard more shit
about when he married that woman and
stuff. You know, married a woman.
Yeah. He married a woman. Whoa. Yeah.
How frustrated was she? She
must've been a really horny,
just sliding around in there. Just
probably didn't know. She's probably rich,
but I think, I think probably maybe it
was just a beard situation. She knows.
But also it's got gotta be a
lot of those pos long drives.
I want to believe that they
can be straight. You know?
That's why they buy the
Whitney Cummings Dick Doll.
But that's where like that all pray
the gay away stuff is, Oh yeah.
You ever heard of those?
Pray the gay away camps guys are
sitting around holding men with boners.
They really get hard ons holding you
and telling you you're not gay. Yeah.
What the fuck's going on back down?
It's fucking crazy. It's like,
it's so wild to not be like, just lean
into what you are, your happiness,
your joy and yeah, but think
about yourself. You were
raised a Quaker would've.
If you raise some wildly, you've
been told that [inaudible],
you know anybody who does that is Satan
worshiper and you're going to go burn in
hell and you live with all this
guilt and sin feeling like that.
Shame that you're rotten
or whatever. I mean,
I definitely have my own shame and I
know probably everyone carries some with
them. I can't imagine on
that scale. That sucks.
That is probably one of the biggest
ones. If you're raised Christian though,
if you're raised like serious
Christian, especially fundamental,
it's one of the worst sins to lay with
another man and just dealing with it.
The deck that they must
get at those camps.
I mean they must just be
pounding each other out.
They probably come so quick cause
you can't believe they're actually,
they're just like,
and then they have that comradery in the
fact that they both are trying to not
be this thing. Oh my God, I'm getting
horny just talking about it. Honestly,
I have a new genre. It's not big foot.
We have to, we have to work through this.
I mean, I'm not getting, you're not gay,
even though we're just fucked. I know.
Just crying in each other's
gay arms. What a sneaky trick.
If you believe in God that
God did, God said, listen,
you cannot have sex with men,
but you're gonna want and you're
nothing really gonna want it.
They're going to want that all
day. You're going to see them all.
Your mostly assholes
all day more than food.
You want them more than water and
you just want to Duke and bought,
do deck bought, ah, firemen and fo
Indians and cowboys,
and then a band's going to come
out and they're all going to play.
It's each part and you're going
to have to try knock some damn,
and then you can't even go
to the YMC anymore. I mean,
if you really believe in Jesus and you
really believe that you shouldn't be gay,
but you are a gay, what a dirty
trick God is. It must be terrible.
I just feel like there's nothing
more dangerous than we're oppressed.
That's gotta be aware of
cancer, not just homosexuality,
but repressing any sort of feelings
like that. It's gotta be what cancer is.
Will repress sexualities. Always
strange. Like when I was in high school,
there was always these girls from Catholic
school and girls from Catholic school
that went to all girls, Catholic
schools with the biggest homes, county.
They couldn't wait to get some
deck because it was so forbidden.
It was a forbidden fruit.
They just would get so excited and
they couldn't believe it was real.
Just fighting off these hormones.
It just has such a terrible trick to
play on a young person to tell them that
their body is dirty and awful and that
these thoughts that are just prevalent,
omnipresent in their mind or their wicked
ways of the devil and that which you
resist persists. You know?
You're just thinking about
that fucking bud hole all day.
Fucking suck in a deck, fat, juicy
hog. He just can't have it. Yeah,
I mean it's terrible. It's really bad.
You guys. Also, if you're out there,
listen, let's just say, let's
God, let God give you a hall pass.
Go fucking asshole. Go
fucking asshole. Go second.
Just move to boys town and realize
like you're going to be fine.
There's a group of them, they get
together and they have a great old time.
There's a parade. They're so
happy if you go down that street
[inaudible] so happy
free. They don't even,
their shoulders are exposed like
there's just a tank tops everywhere.
Just hair shaved. Anything
you want. Just every time.
I love going. I feel invisible. It's
amazing your level. I could just walk,
I could walk bottomless
and they would just,
I've talked to gay guys or they get
mad that straight guys are and straight
girls are going to gay clubs now to
hang out that it's like a weird thing.
Talk to Martindale. Well, I could
see where you'd be like, Hey,
this was like our place to
fuck and now you're here.
Like you're wearing glitter.
Yeah. Get the fuck away. Rainbows.
Member Demitri Martin had that joke
about where he's like, um, gays just get,
I can't, I'm paraphrasing, but gays
just get rainbows. That's not fair.
You just get fractured light, like
greedy, greedy gaze. I mean this is what,
back in the day when you
could say stuff like that,
that was pretty similar about that they
w there was because of duck dynasty,
one of the guys from duck dynasty
was given, I don't get it,
I don't understand why g
and my bit was like, listen,
you should shut the fuck up or the game
people will take over Cammo the same way
they took the rainbow. That's
so funny. They own the rainbow.
The rainbow used to be leprechauns used
to be lucky charms guy who now is gay
people to the point where if I came on
stage with a fucking rainbow tee shirt on
and people would be like, I know I knew
it. We've been waiting for this moment.
Fucking knew it. But um,
the idea was that if a,
like what all the gay cop guys would
have to do is start every gay porn in a
duck blind. Oh my God. Every
gay porn would start with that.
So they're wearing cammo and the duck
hunting and then someone would come in,
a black eye would come in and go,
somebody [inaudible] make me home.
That like duck whistle thing. Oh my
God. My friend worked on my friend Mike,
who I stayed with worked on duck
dynasty. So he knows all those guys.
And what'd he say?
That seemed like a trip or the bud
fucking all the time when no one,
I don't think so. But you know,
it is funny when you take just a family
and then you make them stars and then
you know the cross between
reality and yeah, all that stuff.
And then they go crazy and then they
all of a sudden they're on their own and
they get interviewed and then they say
something really crazy. Trinity Man.
Hello? Not, yeah, some TMZ guy
puts a camera in their face. Yeah.
Are they still doing that show? I
don't think so. How could they stop?
It seems like it was just printing money.
Yeah. I wonder, I mean maybe they are.
I know my friend doesn't work
for them anymore, but yeah,
you ain't still doing duck dynasty.
I don't think so.
Yeah, I don't,
I give him the credit for duck
dynasty whether he wants it or not.
I don't know how that show
final episode, March 29th,
2017 how does that show end ever?
It feels like a smart producer
should step in and go, hey guys,
it's been a couple of years.
I'm on a lot of wacky stories.
Falls asleep with a cigarette in their
mouth. I don't know. It's gone. Yeah.
All that Cammo gone.
It's just, it's weird.
I mean if you watch that show it's like
there's nothing compelling about it at
all. But it was an enormous hit. Yeah.
Just a bunch of people doing duck stuff.
There is something about reality
TV that where you're just like,
it's so thoughtless. You just don't have,
you're just being taken on this
dumb dumb ride. There's like this.
It's just there's nothing happening.
It's like, all right. Yeah.
Next thing you know you're watching
people dissect a storage container. Yeah.
But you know what I'd really
like is survivor. That one.
I still like survivors still like
survivor I think is the number one reality
show cause it's making people,
it's taking away all of their comforts
and they still have to communicate with
each other like games with each
other. They have to, they're starving.
They have to do these
physical, it's still,
you're watching people be like tested
and put, what season is that on?
Oh my God, it's, there's so many
seasons. Like season 1 million.
I've seen all of them.
It's so good. I don't,
I don't pay attention to them fully
so I can rewatch them at some point.
I've watched them a couple of times. That
show was on before fear factor. So I,
we started fear factor in 2001 so that
show was probably on in 2019 years later.
It's in the thirties now. 30 seasons
or something. 33rd yeah. Yeah.
I'm embarrassed. I don't know cause
that's how much it was still a hit. Yeah.
It's amazing. Listen, people either
are on to or they're not yet.
Well, they've actually done 38
episodes or seasons somehow it says,
but this is the 30th. Yeah,
they do several a year now.
Is it still Jeff probe?
It's still Jeff probes. He's still
the host. It's still under the radar.
Like Jeff probes. Just like catch
those checks and stays home. Yeah,
but here's the deal. I've
seen him driving around.
He had his little summer for
Dora. He was riding in his Prius.
I was like drugs ics. This
was like three years ago.
I saw him driving around stockpile
and all the cheese. Yeah.
Maybe he's rich dad. Poor Dad. No,
I mean he must have all his
money just stocked away.
He's driving around in a Prius. He's the,
he's, I love the show. Maybe no good.
They could take this away from him
at any moment. Somebody replaced him.
Would you notice this part of the show?
I think people would be upset. There'd
would be upset. What would be upset?
I think people would be very upset.
I think they'd be extra upset.
But if Adam Carolla took a spot,
um, they would get canceled.
People be like Trump now, is he
a Trump supporter? I think so.
I think so, but I don't know for
listen, I don't know for sure.
I don't want to call anyone
anything. I think he's conservative.
I think he is a Trump supporter though.
Some people get conservative when they
start making money though. I listen,
I everyone has the right to be whatever
the fuck they are. Or you think?
I think so. What about Nazis? They have
the more of a right. A third, right?
I don't think that's right.
Something that's a different word.
What does that even mean? What
does Third Reich? I don't know.
I don't even literally don't. I mean
I've know what the Third Reich is,
but I don't even know what
it means to you. Guess.
I've literally have no idea what that
means. I know it means the Nazis, right?
There's like, but what does it mean in
German? But isn't that a funny thing?
Like that's like Third Reich is
like everyone knows not that,
but no one knows what the fuck
that means. Atomology yeah,
you with the big words. I know a few.
What does it mean third regime
or empire or third realm?
Huh. So the third version of the
Nazi party was the holy Roman Empire,
which lasted until 1806.
The second would be 1871 to
1918 and this was the third.
Interesting. So they were just,
they were considering themselves to
be the third rulers of the world,
like the Romans. Interesting.
Yeah. What a mess in the past.
The thing is that that was not that long.
It was not that long ago. It
was not that long ago at all.
If you're see the video of Hitler
tweaking at the 1936 Olympics tweak like
speed, he was on serious speed.
We were um, um, with Brian Moses,
Brian Moses was saying that Hitler was
into bull semen and I was like, what?
He's like, yeah. And then
we found out that Taurine,
which is in a red bull
actually is from bull semen.
That's why like red bull do this.
That's Hitler tweaking. Oh my God,
look at him. Go straight up
tweaking at the Olympics.
So he was on all kinds of
crazy speed. And then we read
this thing about how he was like
incredibly fatigued and almost dying.
And He, um,
got injected with testosterone and cocaine
and [inaudible] and then went in and
talked Mussolini out of leaving the war.
Cause Mussolini wanted to get
the fuck out of World War II.
And Hitler went and just talked at him
for five hours, just raw. They were
all coked up and oxycodone doubt
bull come dripping down his throat.
Oh my God. How did he get, how did he
extract the bull? Come, I don't know.
But bull semen apparently has this taurine
stuff in it and they extract taurine
from some other method to make the
torrents and the guys at the gay pride,
the gay away camp to that's there
to take your job from the tap.
They're extracting his dick. You
deserve all that. Well, do you remember,
I was thinking about that
horse and zoo, the documentary.
That documentary is amazing.
That video of the, Whoa,
I'm so trying and the part that I'm
traumatized by is not the fucking part.
Okay. And do you remember this scene?
Okay. So he gets up on the bucket, right.
And then you know,
they need like several people to grab
this giant Horse Cock and put in his ass.
And then the horse rams them
only once and then he goes,
this is the part that got me.
Yes. He looks back and he goes,
did he come like he was so concerned if
the horse came, I was like, oh my God.
Yeah. And the guy made a noise like
noise where you're dying because you
fought. He was, he died so soon after.
And then his friend
goes too much. Too much.
Like did you get too much worse? Got
Too much. Of course. Like, and he did.
He died. If you look at the math,
the size of a Horse, Dick, oh,
I have a body cavity. It's
like, where's it going? Yeah.
What's getting out of the way to
make room for that Dick? Oh boy.
They dropped him off at the, at
the hospital. They rolled him out.
He was bleeding. He bled out. He
had bled out from his asshole.
And that's how it happened. I don't think
he did. You don't think he was like,
maybe this was where the hell
did you. If the horse had come,
do you think you would have been worth
it? He would've thought it was worth it,
but do you know that this whole thing,
they had hundreds and hundreds of hours
of footage of him getting fucked by
donkeys and horses and a bunch of other
people that these people had met online
and the zoophilia right is the,
the medical terminology for someone who
is sexually attracted to farm animals
and so or animals period.
And so these people all met online in
some chat room and then decided to get
together in Washington state where
it was still legal to fuck animals.
There's like only a few states where
it's okay. So funny that you had,
there has to be a law. Yeah. There
has to be a lot of tape. So happy.
That's not what you're
into. I'm just like,
I just wake up so grateful and
blessed. I go, thank God. Right.
Could you imagine if that was
your, your oh trick God, thank you.
You can't control that, right?
If he gets something like
some people are in the feet,
some people are in the getting fucked
with hours. I was segwaying into feet,
huh? Yes. People are in
the fee. Have you heard?
I've heard they're in the
fee. I can't believe it. Well,
I was reading up on it that it's the
part of the brain that handles your
genitals and your feet are
right next to their adjacent.
So sometimes the why they think
that the wires get crossed because,
and the guy that studied it was a guy who
studied a phantom limb syndrome and he
was so he was falling when these people's
brains where they would feel that they
still had a foot or whatever
and some guys would get horny,
it would get their brain. So
it was just like crossed, Huh?
We get horny thinking
of their own, not foot.
It's hilarious how you pixelate
your feet and all those pictures,
how they get started.
They just, people were,
they started a Wiki fee account for me.
I just didn't know my feet were a thing.
I just didn't know. I thought I was
just walking around and you know,
in slides didn't know I was
walking around him as well.
Just have been bottomless.
I may as well have just been wearing
like Pajama bottoms with the ass flap
backwards open. Just put, I mean,
my little feet pussy is just
walking around. So then, um,
once people,
I noticed the Wiki feed thing and then
people were damning me all the time to
see my feet and I just was like, you
don't get this was pixelated them
[inaudible] Whitney shares dms with us
sometimes. So it's funny. Group chat,
I'm in with
the Nick Swardson Bristolian Whitney
and she'll post pictures of her dms.
It's like, what in the
fuck? Yeah, they're wild.
I do a thing on my podcast and on my
live stream some times where I sage my
pussy at the end of the night.
So I get sage and I just, yeah,
I just to break the, the negative
Dick Cores that were sent to me,
the unwanted Dick Cords from
all these dudes, I'm like, Yo,
put your Dick cords away. Right.
But you know, people are pervs.
What are you going to do?
I just make fun of them,
but it's more guys that are pervs and
girls that are pervs with stuff like feet
and stat. I think they're a thing that
girls are into. That's kind of gross.
The money. It's so gross.
But that makes sense.
Like money can keep you like your job.
Some people are into like the money fat
guy. Some people are into, I don't know,
people are into all different
things but, but not in the same way.
Like not the same. You're
right. It's not the same.
Some guys are in effect girls too,
but there's a big difference between
that and feet. Men are just very gross.
You're gross, but it's biologically
your dicks or just your just ruled beer.
Dick's are just dragging you through
the world and it's just gotta be
acknowledged. We can't pretend this isn't
a thing just dragging you. It's just,
that's not, we're like breastfeeding and
shit. We're thinking about other shit.
In the archery, there's a term
called front of center, meaning, um,
how much weight is in the front of the
Arrow had th determines like how much
penetration the Arrow will have on
an animal. I'm getting so horny.
This is so weird. What
are you talking about?
It's like the same thing with dicks.
It's like dicks or like your front of
center. It's like, yeah, no they're just,
I I like,
I feel like you guys should be like
holding yourselves back to the doorways
cause your dicks are pulling you through
things and it makes life a lot easier
when you just realized
that. But I think he,
it's like I just have only grown up
a girl so I just didn't, you know,
I knew obviously cause I've had a lot
of sexual attention even very young.
But it's, it's just like
your decks are thing,
they're fucking things and the 7 billion
people and stuff because it's not
necessarily because women
are that horny. Right?
It's just dudes are trying so hard
to fuck. And now these compelled,
I mean this is an evolutionary thing
and it used to be really hard to stay
alive. Yeah. Not that long ago.
Now it's really easy and we're kind of
left with the burden of this shift. Yeah.
We haven't,
our brains and our biology hasn't really
caught up to the fact that we don't
need to have as many people as
we used to. We used to, you know,
used to have a 50% mortality
rate amongst children.
It was very difficult to survive. And I
think that's also was just in China too.
You're seeing more shifting with,
um, you know, like, like those,
those guys in that video, these Beta guys,
the one guy calling out for people to
stop being distracting and the other one
calling out for people to stop
using gendered language. Like, well,
who are they? Well, they wouldn't
survive if there was a, you know,
the Roman army was invading,
they would have never made,
I wonder who's fucking
them? Nobody. Nobody.
Maybe they're just men that aren't
driven by that, you know? No,
that's not true. That's just as good
as they can get. They'd just be jeans,
circumstances and stuff are a
mess. It's a mess. They're a mess.
This is just weird. How much on survival,
how much of our like cave man shit is
still there and how much of this survival
stuff like I've been doing listening
to a lot of therapy podcasts,
just one called the adult chair to this
woman Michelle Chalfont and she's just,
it's all about dealing like with your
inner child and then I'll and all of your
instincts.
She has like the adolescent chair and
the adult chair and your adolescent chair
is all of your ego and your emotions
and your fight, fight or flight,
like all of that. The stuff that
you do, the procrastination,
whatever is your problem,
like why is that happening?
There's something that's coming from
either your child chair or something from
your childhood or things like socially
when you have social anxiety and panic
attacks and stuff,
so much of it could be just back from
in the days if you were ex-communicated
from your tribe, like you would die
if you weren't a part of the club,
you would fucking die.
Whitney Cummings that that's the reason
why people are afraid of public speaking
is that when you were
speaking in front of a group,
you were trying to save your life.
You were trying to plead
your case for the most part,
unless you were the leader of the tribe.
Most of the people were
just trying to say, please,
I didn't know and don't kill me. Is
that how you feel walking around me?
And they know, but some people they
comedy started. People were like, no,
they're still full king. No. You
know how I feel walking around.
I feel like they don't, it's
like they don't have anybody,
but here's the way to put, when you
are listening to someone all the time
and then that person's in your ear,
the person becomes like a weird part
of your life and then you meet them and
you're like, whoa, this is crazy that
you're right here. I've experienced that.
When I first met Anthony Bordain,
I was weirded out. I was like,
I can't believe you're right
here. This is so weird. I see on,
and I've gotten used to that over time,
but still it's strange when
I meet famous people. Yeah.
You know when I meet and it's even
weirder when I made famous people and they
know me, I'm like, yeah, okay, yeah.
The way we can famous people together.
Like hi,
I know. Yeah, I've seen
that before at fucking one,
two famous people just see it.
And then you're just already,
you're already in this weird club
of famous people. It's strange.
Automatically a famous
people club. Well it's, it's
not a normal state and it's not,
I mean, and people that are,
that enjoy the podcast and becomes a
part of their life and maybe it benefits
them and maybe they start
getting motivated and cleaning
up their life and start
being healthier and exercising and
eating better and it, and then,
then it becomes just like almost
like a religion kind of thing.
But because it becomes a thing
that you think of, you know,
in terms of like how to benefit your
life, how to live in a positive way.
You think about the things that
you learned on the podcast?
Almost like you would look at a
religious doctrine. You look at the,
the teachings of Christ, you know,
you look at the teachings of
Moses or you look at like, Oh,
what Rhonda Patrick said was dance.
Oh well you know what Graham Hunt Hancock
was talking about that like in their
head you're like a hired
coach, both of them.
And there's certainly a bit of that.
And it's also represents my own quest to
try to figure out my own life and to do
it publicly and explain what I've learned
and how I failed and have what I've
gotten better at. It helps other
people when you hear that cause you go,
Oh okay, I'm not alone. Like,
cause people think that if like
your life is in order right now,
that has always been like that. So I
think it really helps people to hear like,
oh I used to be a
fucking loser. And I did.
And I used to be scared to talk to
bank Keller tellers. And it was true.
I used to be weirded out
socially. I was very strange.
How can they hear your voice over the
Cha Ching, Cha Ching, Cha Ching to chin.
Cause you're rich. So rich.
You're my richest friends
probably. I'm guessing. Probably.
I can't imagine who's richer. Well
someday you'll be rich too. I can't wait.
We'll laugh. You have
laughed at me before.
Will you get those same kind of glasses
but surround them with diamonds? Yeah,
I want to get jewels. I can see those.
How long do you think it's going to take
to surround them with diamonds? Yeah,
just ordered them.
You don't even think about it because
you're too busy doing other things.
I'm so busy, so busy.
I'm culturally appropriating with those
hoop earrings cause I don't think that's
[inaudible]. Have you
heard my jug about that?
Know about how I got accused of cultural
appropriation for wearing these hoops.
Hilarious. Because uh, but she was
Jew. My, my best friend, she's black.
But I did, I did a slide them
off her neck. She's African.
I do want to be a part of
her tribe. That's the joke.
That is the craziest shit when they
stretch that neck out with those things.
I know, I'm like,
this is when you can get mad at the
Jenners for cultural probe is when they've
had the lip plate [inaudible]
you know what I mean?
When they come with the
stretched out thing. Yeah.
It's just a cultural preparations.
A weird, I don't know.
I think we should all be dressing like,
I think it's cool that we all should be,
I think people should be dry.
I mean you shouldn't be like
disrespecting people's culture and stuff,
but I don't know what,
it just seems like a,
what we're calling culture appropriation.
Today's people looking for
a reason to complain. Yeah.
Cultural appropriation is one of the
reasons why cities are so interesting
because we share each other's food.
We share each other's clothes and listen
to each other's music and you know
where each other's jewelry. It's nonsense.
And you know what's interesting is like
how many people from America are upset
about things,
but then when people from China or Japan
find out that we're wearing a Chinese,
like Japanese [inaudible], they're
so pissed. No, they like it.
I feel like there's been times where
I've just done stuff online, you know,
I'll have a beer or whatever,
and then someone else starts doing it
and you don't, you get mad at that. Well,
that's different. Not as,
it's not a joke. I mean,
just like a thing I'm doing that's
different because then you feel like
someone's copying you, you know,
summarize at a time. But then some people,
some people get mad like,
oh, I'm doing a podcast. No,
he's doing a podcast copied me. Like,
Hey, fuck face. You don't own podcast.
That's where a dick, I have a
podcast. It's called Asian experience.
That's fine.
I've literally had that conversation
with people where they were like, ma'am,
but now he's doing a podcast. I'm like,
what are you talking about? Stupid.
There's 600,000 Fox to do with
you just focus on aim your Arabic,
like handle your own life. It's,
it's so, but your own shit.
I have lived as a victim
for many years. It's,
there is a benefit to it because
you're always fed it. You know?
If you are looking at the
world that you're a victim,
you will be given everything you need
and please don't stop using gender.
Actually, you're going to be so,
everyone's going to be disappointing you.
Everyone's going to be upsetting you
or you can just accept some fucking
responsibility and it feels so good.
It feels good. It does feel good.
Yeah. I mean it feels
good to be calm and to,
to just be at peace and you know
there's a lot of work involved in that.
You've got to fucking, you
got to meditate. You got
to iron out your own stuff.
You got to exercise. It's a progress.
Work in progress. Yes. We all are.
I'm fucking trying man. I'm fucking
trying. I've wrapped this up.
If anybody wants to see you, you are
at the comedy store on a regular basis.
You've got any other dates that
the comedy started? Regular basis.
I'm at the Blue Room and Missouri.
What's the Blue Room? Let's
look it up right in the city.
In Missouri or is it just you have to
find it in the state. It's a big state.
Is there a place look at up. All
right. I should have had this.
I don't even know where you are.
When is this a Springfield, Missouri.
Talking to the microphone. It's in
Springfield, Missouri. When is that?
It
is
not this weekend. Next weekend.
It is on August 17th and 18th
in Springfield, Missouri.
A website where people can,
any letterman.com and any
Letterman on is to her Instagram.
I'm also at go bananas October
the third weekend in October.
In which one go bananas
in Cincinnati. Beautiful.
Um, end of October 2nd to last weekend.
I should have filed these ready and my
new podcast mean Spiration on all things
comedy. What is it called? Means
operation. Operation. Yeah. Okay. Annie,
thank you. Thank you, Joe. Good to
see you, my friend. I'll see you.
I'll see you tonight.
Hi everybody. Hi Guys.
Yeah, that's fine.